now
we are live
brilliant
right good afternoon everybody
welcome to
tonight's
committee meeting planning b wednesday
the 12th of august just in time flying
um my name is council andy crump and i
will be chairman for this meeting
um from a housekeeping point of view
members will have been provided with the
council's ethic etiquette for virtual
meetings in advance of this meeting
however to reiterate the main points
please ensure your device is fully
charged or is charging
please mute microphones when not
speaking
please indicate in the chat bar
or with a hand
item you wish to speak
when invited to address the committee
please ensure your microphone is
switched on
and switch off immediately once you are
finished please ensure you have switched
off or to silence any devices that may
interrupt the proceedings or your mobile
phones that suddenly play the great
escape
if any member encounters id problems
causing them to drop out of this virtual
meeting they should use best endeavors
to rejoin as quickly as possible should
the member be unable to rejoin the
committee meeting they will deem to have
left the meeting at that point
and the meeting will continue provided
it remains correct
please note that the meeting is being
broadcast live and that members of the
public are able to view the proceedings
um
right we normally in advance confirm
that
members of the committee are in
attendance and can hear and see but we
didn't get around to that today so we
need to go through
one by one that so you can give us
assurance that you can see and hear the
proceedings
um
this will you be reading and who's going
to be reading out the the list
yes chairman i'll read the letter and if
we start with yourself chairman
uh
council crump president can seen her
proceedings
thank you councillor fielding
currency
here and see when i get my mute off
thank you councillor fleming
cancer fleming i can see and hear the
proceedings clearly thank you
thank you councillor harvey
councillor harvey you can hear and see
thank you
thank you councillor henshawserafin
councillor henshaws elephant can see and
he hear the proceedings
councillor kettle
councillor kettle i can see and hear the
proceedings
thank you and councillor mills
council mills i can see and hear the
proceedings thank you chairman
thank you
right
um
also president online with me are
offices from democratic services legal
and planning
public speakers will be given a
30-second warning joining the speaking
time
once finished speaking the committee may
wish to ask you questions so please
remain in the meeting if there are no
more questions you can leave the meeting
and continue to watch the proceedings
via the live broadcast
when planning committee members vote
could they please ensure that they
identify themselves clearly and speak
into the microphone so that their vote
is understood clearly both by other
members of the committee and also those
watching the webcast
members should respond
for against
or abstain
and again i just emphasized that this is
webcast please stick to the protocols
and procedures and i know um democratic
services have sent out an email recently
uh with the pharisees and
best practice during community meetings
so if you had a chance to peruse that
that would be great as well
right we now move to the agenda
so
item one on the agenda to receive any
apologies for absence
show me apologies from councillor wrong
thank you
disclosures of interest
item two hub members
uh any disclosures of interest they need
to
register now
that's the fielding
for the rarely site which is number i
haven't got a hand i received a letter a
copy of a letter from i think the agent
about
the site
but uh
it has i'm still very open-minded
yes thank you
sorry can i just confirm which site it
was you can indeed
um oh god application was it twenty zero
zero fives there was a land off barely
wrote snitterfield yeah
did you all receive it
give me yes
is that okay everybody
everybody clearing that yeah
right
good
i will decline in
cancer
i think counselor kettle is waving
uh yes thank you mr chairman um just
whilst i visited um all those sites
which i could get access to
um the smithfield site
um i did go on site and have a look
around and met and spoke
to the um one of the operators there uh
who showed me around however that is not
um i'm coming to meeting with open mind
was a bit slow coming up and i just
noticed you had indicated to speak as
per the proper procedure via the the
chat process so thank you for that uh
counselor harvey
uh just just to reiterate um cancer
feelings um fielding's comment that i
too received an email from
um
mr david bishton
uh in connection with the uh application
at the bailey roadside
thank you
i remain open-minded
thank you uh mr nash um
you're indicating
to come in please
i was just going to reiterate can we can
the council's plea please use the chat
function instead of putting the hands up
please chair
thank you
all right thank you
um
right
i need to declare that i am ward member
for application
19603 442 slash f3l welfare center
cravenline saturn
and i've registered to speak so i will
be passing the chairmanship of this
meeting to catch the most of that item
uh
anybody else got any disclosures of
interest on this one
no
uh and the only other thing i will
mention now
is that um
catch the parry
um
i will be reading this statement
on her behalf on the first application
as she wasn't unable to attend and she
had registered at the last meeting and i
agreed to read it out um
there was some confusion on the last
application acorn stores
um the fashion science projector with
with catch the bromitch uh didn't
register speaking time but in the past
we've had
um
agreement and uh president setting that
um i will read out his small statement
ah i've just been told that councillor
parry has just joined and wishes to
speak as ward members so
take that back thank you this um
so
will that ignore my last comment and
we'll
move swiftly on to
item three which is uh
to confirm and so on the minutes of the
meeting held on the 15th of july and i'm
happy that i don't know i'm just looking
for a proposal in the second
that to sign those minutes
catch the kettle
and cast the fielding thank you
are we all agreed
agreed
yes great
raw call chairman
okay
and would you uh happy to do the roll
call please
you south chairman the great caster
crump agreed
cancer fielding
chair sorry chad spotting but i can't
see a second i've seen cancer catalyst
proposed
by the chat function but i haven't seen
a seconder by the chat function
halfway through doing it
okay i think it's the field in was that
council of fielding that said he was
seconding
yes i was in the process of doing it
okay
my name was shouted and you've agreed
okay councillor fleming
council fleming agreed
councillor harvey
council harvey abstain
councillor henshawson
hence yourself and agreed
council mills agreed
that six four was one abstention channel
thank you chair i still haven't got a
second
oh god oh sorry mr it was councillor
fielding he um he hasn't put it in the
chat but he confirmed it when i called
him in to speak
thank you okay
yeah
no
except for spinning's wrong
yep then i won't have to moan through
the night
i'll look forward to that mr nash thank
you right
uh when they move on to our first
application of the night and i think
the storm that counts the field in
gotham is just coming over to southam so
if it just suddenly disappear um cancer
mills be where you might have to take
home
um
thank you
uh
application number twenty zero zero
eight nine three slash fuel eight human
green was born
loft conversion erection of dormer to
the back and four number roof lights to
the front retrospective
all right
and our k-stock sentinel officer is mr
neil hampstead
if you'd like to fire one yeah whenever
you're ready
thank you chairman um i've just tried to
um
share the presentation on the screen can
can everyone see it at all
yeah
yes that's not okay
great thank you very much
um the application is at eight hammond
green um wells born
and the application site is shown on the
screen with the
with the black dot
so the proposal is a retrospective
application for a loft conversion
erection of dormer to the back and four
number roof lights to the front
so just to give some um members a
greater context the application site is
shown in red here
so it's in a residential area and it's a
corner plot
and the um the roof
the the dormer is showing approximately
near that location i've got some plans
to uh to show
now i've also got some photographs um
coming up later in the presentation so
they will be coming
looking in a south easterly direction
here and looking in an easterly
direction from the rear of the property
as well so that's just to give some
members some context in the later part
of the application
so just to give members some some
background to the to the application
um planning permission was granted under
delegated pals in february this year for
a lot of conversion erection of a dormer
to the back and three number roof lights
to the front elevation
now these are shown on the the bottom
plans here so you can see the the dormer
so the rear and you can see the three
roof lights which were previously
granted
now in constructing the um
the the approved development
effectively the dormer window has been
granted has been built larger than
approved
and four roof lights have been built in
the front elevation
and have been moved slightly further
down
um the measurements are clarified in the
update sheet which all members hopefully
should have
uh the proposed use of the loft
extension is to provide an additional
bedroom with ensuite bathroom in line
with the previously approved planning
permission
so to give members um an idea of
what has been built on site i've got
some photographs
so
this is looking um from these two
photographs here are looking from the
rear of
hammond green looking towards the
the application site so
there is the the dormer window which has
been which has been built
and looking from hammond uh hammond
green to the side of the elevator of the
of the property looking up again you can
see the the normal the the normal window
to the rear of the property
and to the front you can see the
four roof lights which are now in situ
as previously mentioned i would bring to
members attention the committee update
sheet that contains clarification of the
measurements in respect of the rear door
window together with some other updates
in respect to the committee report
in conclusion members the application is
recommended for approval with the
imposition of a conditional note the
detailed wording which is delegated to
officers for the reasons stated in the
officers committee report thank you
thank you neil
right
we'll now move on to our first speaker
probably it should be
catch the primer from wellsborne and
walton paris council
can you hear me catch the prior
yes i can
right um you've got three minutes i'll
give you a warning with 30 seconds to go
and if you can far away um
i'm ready to uh
all ready for you to go
okay thank you councillor
as has been stated this planning
application is for building work which
has been done in contravention of the
original planning application
1903 584-4
the parish council feels that stratfor
district council have a duty to enforce
planning applications and not to allow
such breaches to be brought forward as a
new retrospective application for such a
breach
we could as a council and do say that
the dharma put into the building is
significantly larger than that agreed
one counsellor described it as a shed
sticking out of the roof
using the officers figures in the
original documents they stated it was
1.5 metres longer than the original
greed dormer
that does not seem to me despite what
the officer states to be slightly larger
in size and was previously agreed
pre-matrification this is almost five
foot longer
as you drive along hammond green road it
can be clearly seen with no attempt to
make the cladding in sympathy with the
building itself or the roof it's an
eyesore the view for the houses behind
it must be unpleasant as it is an
unpleasant addition to the house itself
there is also the insertion of an extra
velox window to the frontage of the
property
whilst that is not obtrusive it is still
in contravention of the original
planning application
if the applicant is given this
permission retrospectively it sends out
a message to other residents but it's
okay to ignore the planning commission
you have been given and change major
features of it because stratfor district
council will give you permission anyway
after you've done it
we ask that you refuse this application
and that the resident rectifies matters
to meet the previously agreed planning
application
thank you
thank you councillor
well within the time right
um
any questions for the paris council
people come through chat
any any questions or
no
i can't say anything
thank you close to the prior um for your
presentation
thank you
right we'll now move on
to
[Music]
i believe it's mr george gazoozo who's
the agent mr good could do so
are you here sir
yes can you hear me and i hopefully
pronounce your surname correctly i
apologize if i didn't
very good you
gazebo
is very good oh very good you've got
three minutes uh very good we've got
three minutes sir um we'll give you a
warning with about 30 seconds and please
stand the line for any questions from
from cancer so far away when you're
ready please
thank you
whilst we
appreciate the comment that was made
by the previous uh council regarding the
um
the consideration that this could be
uh
allow a
sort of
barn door to be opened on future
developments that have not been approved
it is important to understand in this
instance
that this dormer was not constructed
with
with regard and experience of disregard
for the planning approval it was more to
do with the fact that once the
dormer had uh
started to be set out it was
uh realized that
it would not quite meet the needs of the
the client whose uh autistic child
was um
was needing as much daylight and as long
as possible that's aside
the client obviously acknowledges that
the doorbell has been built
to the incorrect dimensions and they did
not appreciate that
minor changes or these changes would
result in uh
it being challenged and it being a
problem uh but it was very quick
once it was noticed that some of these
didn't meet the
uh approved plans it was very quick to
submit an application in order to set
matters straight so um
we would ask that this is not used as a
case to
beat the client with in terms of uh
insisting
to the letter
because it didn't follow the due process
but request that the officer's
recommendations be followed and if there
are any other things that can be done to
try to
make the appearance of the dormer um
less controversial the client would be
more than happy to consider that
thank you very much
welcome in time
right any questions for the agent please
counselor mills
um thanks mr chairman um
uh mr garuzzo
could you clear this up for me did they
realize that the
that the scale of the drawings were
wrong halfway through when they were uh
constructing this normal window did they
realize
they were wrong but carried on or
did they finish it and realize it was
wrong
yes
a bit to to be absolutely honest with
you i'm not entirely clear um
i believe that the project was carried
out
on behalf of the client by
one of these subcontractors and
i can
i i know that the client
is you know was was distressed by the
the actual committee can hear him either
no i see is that better that's but
i i could anyway that's all i i didn't
have any problems hearing him so um
i'll try and summarize that in a very in
in
in an eventual way i i did ask the
client whether that was the case if he
knew it was being built
to the wrong
dimensions
and the response i got from the client
was that he was unaware until the major
the main framework has been put up
can i ask another question mr chairman
yes cancer mills thank you and does that
go for the extra door my window as well
chair is a chair i'm sorry it's
interrupt again but there's only one
question per member i'm afraid i'm sorry
yep no that's that's fine i thought it
was sort of like a suit right yep
yeah okay
right uh counts the cattle
thank you miss thank you mr chairman can
i just um remind you mr chairman that
actually mr grafton did subsequently
rule that that that uh original email
about one question for a mammal was
entirely the discretion of the chairman
and didn't carry any
uh formal authority
so
in the last meeting we did actually have
multiple questions
authorized by you to
individuals so it would be nice to
continue on that basis because it was
very helpful but i'll go with my
question
i'll go to my question
um
mr caduzo i'm i'm somewhat surprised
when the application says
three that has been approved
and you put four
um dormers in
that isn't a matter of
realizing
that
the room wasn't big enough
that is a clear it's either three or
it's four
could you explain
how your i mean somebody must have
bought the dormers to put them in
could you explain
how
he put in four
ordered four gave instruction to the
builder before
when it says three
okay certainly
can you hear me
yes
first of all we're talking about roof
lights um and
regarding the three that were approved
and the addition of the addition of the
extra roof light the fourth one that
that's the question that you're asking
um i i can only
state that my understanding is that yes
the the fourth roof light
was added uh sim because of the need for
extra light daylight into that room um
it was a matter of ignorance in not
under not appreciating that simply
adding one more roof light
would be a problem um and so i can't you
know it's not a defense it's not a a a
defense it's a statement of fact uh he
uh was unaware
that it would be a a problem and uh
wrongly
uh sort of did progress with that with
the installation of that roof light um
believing that it would be uh acceptable
so
he's certainly
you know being chastised by the the mata
by virtue of the fact that he's had to
pay for additional uh work to be done uh
to you know to to to get this
application in and and is now much more
alert to the fact that you just cannot
um uh alter these uh these plans no
matter how insignificant you think that
the alterations are without first
seeking guidance from the planet
right
thank you very much
any further questions
all right
got no indications
got a comment one but no no comments no
anybody else indicating to speak so we
will know my might may only make to one
show the comment no i'm sorry sorry no
you're not allowed to say no thank you
um
all right
um right we'll now move on to
[Music]
uh i'll believe cancer paris is with us
now cancer party
hello
is there anybody there
i'm here
oh
okay sorry it
it looks like in trying to unmute
perhaps she's just left the meeting let
me just see if i can call her back here
yeah i did have a phone call from
somebody i'm not sure it's a member
trying to get in as well
um if you just bear with me i will take
myself off camera i'm still here i'll
just take myself off camera whilst i
once i check this call
now all right
it looks like she's back in the meeting
chairman
can you hear us
yes i can through the storm sorry about
that i got thrown off yeah
that's
i missed all the past fits but um it's
just the internet's just come back on
again but it's black outside my my
office window
right
um you've got five minutes cancel the
parry i was going to read your statement
out and then they told me you were here
anyway so i'd rather hear from you in
the hip on myself so oh bless you
good evening planning committee b i'm
delighted to join you um
just want to really emphasize
that
i do really recognize the parish
council's concerns regarding this
particular
application um
particularly when it's retrospective
it is larger than what was originally um
approved uh together with that
additional roof light on the front
elevation
um
but when i i have visited the site and i
have looked at it
and i don't believe
that the
um
the the increase in size
brings substantial harm to what was
originally approved and really that's
that's the point where i'm coming from
so i issued actually a no objection to
this
because i feel it would be
churlish to ask the applicant to
uh remove the whole of that
dormer
um
construction
and rebuild it to the exact size that
was was actually approved and i also
feel that if this went to appeal
particularly in view of the government's
new guidelines on
extending your home and moving up
and particularly with an officer's
recommendation for grant
that
the applicant would win on appeal
um i don't particularly like the design
and i do share concerns from the parish
council but purely from
a planning perspective
um
my view was that there was no objection
and therefore um
i don't have an objection to this purely
for those reasons that i think if it
went to appeal
it would it would it would be allowed
and there would be additional costs and
additional time um
but having said that i do understand
where the parish council is coming from
that's all i have to say
thank you councillor barry well within
the five minutes and thank you for
joining in and getting through the storm
i'll probably think of the cancers
around some problems with
their internet connection as well
because of uh the storm as well at
cancer kettle i believe you have a
question for council
um yes councilman perry good evening um
and uh i hope i um last through the um
storm as well
um
council parry we have to decide this
application it's come to committee due
to the parish council's objection on the
planning um merits in accordance with
the mppf and the um
the core strategy
um
and actually prejudging what an
inspector whom we haven't met
um might consider is not something which
falls into the room it's with this
committee i would think
would you like to comment on that it's
our decision at this stage not that of
an a hypothetical inspector i couldn't
agree with you more um and everybody is
entitled to their opinion and of course
the decision rests with yourselves
that's all i have to say
right
any any further calls or questions
to cancel the party please
right i think
that's it catch the pie you're free to
go
stay safe and try not to get too wet in
the horrible weather
right
when i move on to
the debate
i know
just since then it's come up on the
screen
oh catch the harvey
um
i don't know whether you've got a
question for councillor parry um it's
only just come through i didn't i
couldn't see you on the screen either is
it a question for councillor here's the
parry no it was a contribution to the
debate oh good man that's what i'd like
to see thank you
um
we're on to the point of clarification
at first with offices and then um
[Music]
and then we'll go on to the debates any
any other points of clarification for
the officers
cast the cattle
thank you mr chairman um
the parish council pointed out that this
um
um as built extension
does um
suggest um sort of
it sticks out
um part of the
[Music]
um
when i went to look at the site part of
the reason it takes out is it's a very
different color to the roof
uh the existing roof and whilst the
officers report
says that there are a number of
different styles
um in the modern cul-de-sac or varying
styles
um
the majority of all the houses do have a
level of consistency and there's no
other
um
dormer that looks anything like this
particular one across the whole site
um were there any conditions on the
original style
of the dormer
under the approved application
um perhaps you could answer that first
because i then do have a follow-up mr
chairman
thank you councillor can can you hear me
okay yeah we can hear you now yep okay
um
the original conditions that were put on
the um
on the original um
permission
were the standard three-year
commencement one
the details um and drawings had to be
adhered to and the materials as per
the approved plans so those were the
three
um
conditions that were put on the
the original planning permission
thank you mr hammerstein
could you tell me what the approved uh
materials
were and were they identical to what we
see
yes let me see if i can
if i can share my screen again um
um
i may well have the original planning
permission plans on here if you bear
with me
what do i need then
okay
so um
can you see that plan on the on the
screen
spokane thank you neil okay let me just
let me zoom in
so
there is an annotation on the original
plan
um
which talks about the the materials that
applied to the um
to the dormer window
and in terms of the walls it says tree
to timber cladding to dormer
so that that was the um that was the
materials that were um approved
previously counsellor in respect of the
um of of the walling to the to the rear
door window
does the finish actually apply
because it clearly is not a timber color
it's jet black
yes it does appear to be a different
color than as as previously approved
that that's the um
that's the previous color there
thanks mr my question was almost
identical to councillor kettle on
material so i'll pass on that one thank
you
brilliant thank you any other points of
clarification or can we move on to the
debate now
right
all right
we'll move on to the debate who would
like to start on this one then please
german councillor harvey had already
indicated i think to speak
i thought cancer harvey wanted to speak
on
yeah on the debate rather than
clarification yep kessler harvey if you
want to come in thank you mr chairman
um
my view is that uh this is an
application where the parish council uh
council
councillor prior has got it right in the
sense that uh
we are in danger of uh
creating something of a president
she described it or she she commented
that somebody had described
this particular
extension as something of a shed in the
side of a house
i think the officers however have come
to a pragmatic view
whilst it may be a shed inside of a
house it's only slightly larger than the
intended shed inside of a house
i think we have to be realistic and live
in the real world
i think the officers have considered the
matter
they have considered
that the
additional size is not material to the
application and have concluded that
this application should be granted i am
satisfied to rely on their judgment and
consistency and are prepared to propose
that we approve
this particular application
thank you cancer harvey
uh catch the mills i believe you're next
and yes thanks mr chairman um i have to
say when i first looked at this uh i was
a little bit taken aback but uh
uh
the original application was approved
but uh i
to go an extra 15 on the size of that
dormer
and also to put the extra window in um
when it was three
uh
to me that is completely wrong
retrospective to me i'm i'm not that
keen or expected but you know that's not
always the case but um
for me i think the uh
that as trevor said the uh
parish council got this absolutely spot
on and uh i will not going with the
officer's recommendation on this mr
chairman thank you
thank you
catch the folding
i seem to have lost the picture but i
get a second
counsellor harvey i think that uh yes it
is large it could be a different color
if we can agree a change of color
um more in keeping with probably the
brickwork
and also the
color scheme as per the plans but apart
from that i've gotten i will
second what council harvey says
okay
uh we'll go back to that shortly cancer
cattle
um thanks thank you mr chairman um i put
in the comments that um i'm not wishing
to challenge um council mills on his
mass
it isn't 15 it's 21
um
bigger than originally envisaged
um and therefore this is a very
significant increase in
um volume
um in fact the the lineal
horizontal stretch
and if you look at it in terms of
percentage of the full width of the um
[Music]
roof it is a very significant difference
and it seems to me they've gone with one
thing
uh and built something considerably
different
um and therefore i'm completely unsung
where the parish council is coming from
we then have the additional bit of four
not three dormers uh sorry verlux
windows to use their correct words um
again
this isn't a matter of mistake this is
well
let's put the four in rather than three
had they wanted to put four and they
could ask for an amendment at that stage
we then got the third issue of color
um and what struck me when i visited the
site uh immediately before the previous
planning meeting but i'm sure it hasn't
changed since
um was the
black
impact
sticks out like a
proverbial sore thumb
so
we have effects three breaches of
relatively simple application
width is 21
higher
um number of deluxes is 33 higher and
the color's wrong i'm not quite sure
what else they could have got wrong to
be honest unless they've gone up with
somewhat but it was a rich height which
prevented them going any higher
um so i would be supporting councillor
mills position on this
um
council fielding suggested a sort of a
pragmatic version following on from
councillor harvey's wish to be pragmatic
um
and one does try to be helpful
um the difficulty we have is we we've
had somebody who has just not complied
with the three key issues about the
previous application
um therefore
um i'd be interested to hear from the
officer
mr hempstead you see he's still with us
yeah i know but i'd be interested to
know
i don't know
whether mr fielding's proposed condition
that the color is put back into the um
what was originally
planned
could be
implemented because of it can't believe
me implanted then mr fielding seconding
doesn't actually work
um but
i might be prepared to consider that if
we can have confirmation that color can
be changed to the original timber and
kept like that
um if not i will be joining mr mills uh
opposing this application
uh mice can i bring you in on this one
uh would that condition
be
acceptable
i'm slightly confused to be honest with
you chair can nail just confirm that
please
um sorry um mr nash mr feels it
counselor feeling suggested that it
would be acceptable that he'd second it
if the color of the
um
the dormer as opposed to the galaxies
uh
uh put back to that originally planned i
think i'm not putting words in this
field council buildings i'm out on that
one i think uh i think
uh
chair i think tracy would be in a better
position please yeah i've just sent
tonight so tracy's going to come in
please
thank you chairman yes i i absolutely
understand the frustration that members
on the parish council and the neighbours
feel when consent is uh is granted for a
particular scheme and then differences
occur during the course of construction
um it's it's a frustration we uh we have
to deal with uh as as part and parcel of
running authority's functions
of course the applicant is entirely
equally uh allowed to then ask if they
can retain the structure in the manner
in which they
built it and we then have to assess
whether the differences are so harmful
that we should require the the
development to be amended back to the
approved scheme or if it's acceptable in
its current form now obviously we've
provided that analysis in the report and
we do feel that in terms of uh the
residential impact uh and so forth given
the uh um
the fact that the window sizes
themselves are unchanged we do feel that
the neighbor impact is uh is unchanged
from the uh the scale of the proposal
previously uh approved so that's in
essence why we're recommending approval
for this uh this application i am
mindful obviously that the color is
different um and you can see from the
photos obviously that it's a darker
color than the pale gray roof tiles
what i'm anticipating is that if we were
to insist on the materials being changed
then effectively you are asking for some
very substantial revisions to the actual
dormer structure itself
what we could do if the tipping point
for the application for members is the
color issue
we could by condition explore with the
applicant and their agent um if there's
any sort of external treatment be it
paint or or other
amendment to the structure is built now
which might uh tone down the dark color
of the structure i don't necessarily
know obviously without speaking with the
agent what can be achieved but if that
was a particular concern for members and
was the the tipping point for the
application then we could explore that
with the uh with the applicant's agent
and if you wanted to entertain a
condition to that effect we could uh we
could look at that for you thank you
tracy uh cancer flowing
thank you chairman um really from my
perspective um we asked the parish
council to vote on these things and to
give us an indication of what they want
and they obviously approved the original
drawings
so we've got
the the decision to put four windows
instead of three um the agent seemed to
imply that was almost like an accident
so you need a builder that can count
between three and four
um you also must have an elastic tape
measure because you can't certainly go
one and a half meters longer than the
original
the original plan and think well that'll
be okay because nobody will notice um
and it seems to me like it's been a
total disregard for what the original
plan was so the the actual householder
or the you know the resident and the
builder themselves and the agents it's a
three-way way three-way uh sign-off for
making something that was totally not in
keeping with the original plan
so from my perspective i probably won't
be uh won't be supporting the grant
application really
that's all i'd like to say thank you
thank you casa fleming um right we've
had a proposal from councillor harvey
and cancer field in a second and
indicated in the chatties he's appears
to be happy with um
chase's uh
summing up uh comments regarding finnish
etc so
i think we need to go to the vote um
so
the proposal is
to grant the application
um
as per the officer's report
aren't we exploring um
tracy's comments as well chairs so
is that coming back to
um you know the actual paints
uh external coloring to be confirmed
say with yourself
was that
what was discussed i do believe
more sickly than i can
yeah
if you'd if you'd like me to do that
chairman what we could do is
place an additional condition on
to seek
further details of external treatment
we'll have that discussion with the
agent to see what if anything can be
done we'll report that back through the
chairman
and hopefully if there is a um
a method of softening the color of that
then we'll be able to achieve it by
condition which we can then put out
through the chairman um and obviously if
the answer is no then if members
or the chairman was insistent on it then
coming back for committee to decide uh
finally then uh obviously he has the
authority to uh to instruct us to bring
it back to you
let me go back to councillor harvey
first because it was his proposal
and then back back to cancer fielding
hello
mr harvey can you hear i can hear what
would you like me to say are you happy
with
um
potential of another condition in
addition an additional condition
for
the paints to finish etc um
to
be is one of the conditions and for it
to be agreed by the officers in the in
accordance in association with myself
um if approval was a given and if no
agreement could be agreed
um it would have to come back to
committee
i'll have to go along with that
chairman right
um hello
hello hello sorry
you is that the agent
yeah sorry uh yeah
i'm afraid
no
no it's just about changing the cladding
these guys may
sorry the agent needs to be quite sorry
yeah that's what i'm saying you can't
come in i'm afraid
right
um
we need the roll call from andow please
chair yep
and are you ready
i am
i saw yourself chairman
against
councillor fielding
councillor fielding for
councillor fleming
councillor fleming against
councillor harvey
council harvey iv
and henshaw seraphin
against
okay chairman that is two four one two
three four five against
bit fours
fours now we need a
proposal to
refuse the application
um
so
and also with some reasons as well
please chair
come on mate i was just about to come to
that yeah you know me better than that
sorry
appropriate planning reasons for a
refusal yes okay
catch the nails
oh yes thanks mr chairman yes um
can we put here
we're against all planning um
well there's obviously no planning uh
advice
uh
[Music]
sort on this
um can we put in
just have 100 percent against the plans
that were submitted
i think with what council power did say
about appeal we'll need proper planning
reasons
uh if the um
uh applicants decide okay
okay it's it's it's it's four dormers
four windows instead of three
it's 21
larger than originally um stated so i i
think personally i think that's that's
good enough um somebody's trying to take
the mick here
i'm sorry too well
so a significant
uh
deviation from the original application
that makes it not in keeping with the
street scene
um
is is that what you're trying to say
against them yes yes i think thank you
very much mr jim i'm sure i'm gonna be
upset here yeah uh totally not including
the street scene thank you
cancer cattle
um thank you mr chairman i was going to
ask our planning manager
um to guide us on this one
um
but it would appear to me and i'm sure
some people will be able to do that
um but my
view would be under positive cs9
um
that it's not high quality design
the existing estate
has a pleasing finish
um and there is a certain consistency
without the throughout the estate of
which this individual property form is
part thereof
um
the coloring
the size
um are not consistent with the existing
um
high quality design of the rest of the
estate and therefore um if you look at
cs9 part b
um it does not increase integrate with
the existing form
um
it is distinctive for the wrong reasons
um it isn't sensitive to the setting
layout and orientation of the rest of
the the estate the neighbouring uses the
landscape
um and personally b1 it is not
particularly attractive
um
i can't see any other parts of cs9
which um which support this application
it is not innovative design
um and therefore it has i don't there's
nothing on the cs9 which actually gives
any support to this application
um
i'd be very helpful for ms humphrey's
um help on this to see whether any other
policy areas which she feels might be
appropriate to help the committee on
this matter
yeah tracy
chair i'm not too sure yet um
tracy can actually clarify the reasons
put forward by the counselors but she
cannot go over reasons support reasons
in in the counsellor's mouths i'm sorry
no i i think no i don't think well i'm
perhaps misunderstood or misheard but
i think
that
i think the reasons that counts the
kettle has come out with are substantial
that they do hold weight um but i think
what counselor kettle was asking was to
make sure that
tracy had got those and she was able to
put them in the form
uh get the feeling and the flavor from
the from the council's opinions able to
put them in the form that was able to
stand up to
um
scrutiny shall we say maybe i
misinterpret which is what councillor
castle said then i do apologize yeah
tracy yeah yeah thank you chairman yes
i've been listening and making notes i i
think what uh um counselor kettle in
particular is identified is members main
concern is design and appearance
of uh of
the dormer principally i think is what
you're saying please correct me if
that's if if my notes are incorrect um
clearly if you're going to refuse the
application we need to identify what the
planning harm is from the development as
we see on the ground now so merely it
being different isn't it in itself
planning harm you need to clearly
identify what you feel to be the
planning harm reasons and from what
you've just summarized in the debate
there it sounds like you're focusing on
design and appearance and counselor
kettles mentioned uh one core strategy
policy you've got strategy policy nine
in particular um the legal office is
quite quite right uh we
we can't suggest what any other concerns
you might have uh are but if that
doesn't encapsulate your concerns now is
the time for members to say if you have
any additional planning harm issues that
you've identified from
from the scheme as it stands at the
moment
so at the moment we've got we've got
design and appearance concerns if
there's anything else you need to say so
now um what about the sky on considering
it's 21 bigger than the original
approval
uh yes you need well you need to root
that in what you feel the harm is that
arises from that not merely that it's
bigger
i would assume that
sure just it's just a street scene mr
chairman
um
and the scale of the development and
impact on street scene yes i would say i
think that's what you're what you're
summarizing to officers you'd like us to
devise some reasons for refusal on those
grounds thank you tracy
could you use cs5
visual impact
um
hmm
right well cs5 is the landscape policy
and it really talks about landscape
character and quality of the district
uh although it does talk about visual
impacts also trees woodlands and hedges
and so forth
um
i think we're probably best sticking to
what we've got i think we've got three
or four
relative strong reasons i think that's
good enough mr j it does refer to
townscape
yeah i think
i'm concerned about overreacting the
pudding and if these are not quite as
strong that one is not as strong as the
other of the three that we've got
um
uh i'd rather we stick to the three
three stroke four strong loans that
we've got so
um
i'm happy that we
so council mills did you
are you proposing refusal for the
reasons that
we've just indicated
yes mr chairman
and did you second that cancer kettle
sorry sorry yes uh i've been seconding
that
okay
i think we need to go to the vote then
okay chairman we start with you
counselor come
for
council of fielding
abstain
councillor fleming
cancer fleming four
come to la harvey
council harvey against
councillor henry
and serenity
in four
kettle
can't hear you chris
you're muted chris
cows for kettle four
committee um
um i'm happy for the
uh we've given sorry before we move on
most i just need to clarify that i'm
happy
that um the reasons um
can be delegated to to officers uh we've
uh
we've given our opinion on what we'd
like to see um are you uh is that okay
from a legal point of view just
basically the committee resolves to
refuse pending application
number and
just subject to confirmation on the
refusal
uh reasons with youtube yep
right thank you just making sure
committee resolves to review his
application
20 000 893 full
with
the reasons to be confirmed by officers
with mrs chairman
thank you i will now move on to the next
item we'll have a small interval because
of the process of
virtual meetings
and when we can come back catch the
mills we'll be chairing this item and
please remember even though we're
in a small break members of the public
can still hear our comments so
please just
keep them professional and
uh asking questions about uh
um
items so not uh
talking about the weather i'm afraid so
all that i will leave you shortly and
when you come back cancel the mills
we'll be cheering the meeting thank you
oh
oh you're going to be careful he's at
you too
chairman we're ready to begin if you're
back in the room
i certainly am
i'm back in
yes
i'm here i can't see anybody else there
it doesn't matter you can't see anybody
as long as you can hear and see the
proceedings when they start
okay
um
i'm ready to start and if
you can you could start counsellor nails
can i start okay but i can't see i saw
i'm so sorry i couldn't see anybody else
on the screen um
right on the second item on the agenda
this evening is application 19 stroke
zero three double four two stroke
fuel and it's the welfare center craven
lane sell them
uh it's the demolition of existing
billet hut
and the proposed erection of two
semi-detached dwellings
thank you and um the case officer is um
joseph brooke over to you joe
thank you chair uh let me just set up
the presentation
[Music]
uh can everybody see that
yes thank you joe
thank you joe
thank you
uh
the site is located when the physical
confines are southern as indicated by
the black dot before you
the application is seeking planning
permission to demolish the existing
billet hut and develop two two and a
half storey semi-detached dwellings with
private immunity space on the
application site as indicated by the
plan for you so quite obviously this is
the existing hall and that is the
application site
it should also be noted that the
application is contained in the southern
conservation area and in close proximity
to a number of listed buildings
as set out in the officer's report
the dwellings are proposed to be two
bedroom dwellings and will be
constructed out of brick dental coursing
sas style upcc windows with lead
finished normal windows and dark gray
slate as you can see
front elevation side elevation
brick
normal windows
this is the rear elevations and the east
facing side elevation
so a 1.8 meter boarded fence will be to
the rear elevations as well by fold
frames to match the sash windows
the dwellings will be set to 8.5 meters
to ridge will also be combined width of
8.5 meters and in an overall depth of
8.6 meters the dwellings if approved
would be sight to the front of craven
lane as demonstrated on the street scene
before you
and keeping the same development line as
the neighboring properties
this is the photo of the existing billet
hut which would be demolished if
permission was forthcoming
uh please note the state and the repair
as indicated in the report
this is the street scene facing down
craven lane so this is enabling
two-story properties
this is the row of shops it's also
situated along the lane and this is also
a residential dwelling facing directly
across the application site
this is facing upwards to crave a lane
as you can see craven court which is a
three-story apartment box
and also this building here is listed by
virtue of being attached to the grade 2
listed building here
this is to rear the application site so
we're in the parking area which isn't as
part of the application so you can see
the billet hut to the right
these are the um type of free story
three-story apartments that are also
situated in the vicinity this is the
neighbouring dwelling um on craven lane
and these are also the dwellings and
apartments that face behind craven corps
once again examples of three-story
buildings within the vicinity
and that's the end of presentation
in consideration the area's development
plan national policy and guidance as
well as the relevant statutory
consultations the officer's
recommendation is on plane balance
as set out and you have to report
approval subject to the recommended
conditions
as you will see in the update sheet the
officer has recommended for one
additional condition for detailed site
and finish floor levels to be submitted
if permission is for forthcoming thank
you
thank you joe um
but we go to our
first speaker it is a councillor john
from the
parish council
or southern town council i'm so sorry um
mr john can you hear us
please
recommended for one additional condition
finished
please
playing in the background while you are
speaking
yeah
the speaker it is
so there's still another device playing
in the background so we're getting
feedback and we can't hear you so you
will need to mute what happened
i thought i had muted it
okay it sounds like you might have done
now if you continue and if it's a
problem we can let you know okay thank
you
thank you
thank you council you've got three
minutes
okay thank you
the time council objects to the
subscription on two specific accounts
the application proposes the replacement
of a modest-sized derelict wooden hut
with specific historic references with
two dwellings on a relatively small plot
cited within a conservation area it's
the council's submission that they are
in question and the directly adjacent
narrow roadways including the one-way
craven lane itself will not support the
proposal in its current form the time
council has requested in three separate
consultation responses that the
conservation officer be consulted that
there appears to be no correspondence to
evidence that this has occurred
our feasible concern relates to the lack
of on-street parking the site itself
lies directly off craven lane with a
parking area for use by the residents of
overlooking flats
no on-site parking is planned rather
it's expected prospective residents
would park vehicles off-road if spaces
are found in surrounding streets
the council can test this arrangement on
the basis it conflicts with the parking
standards guidance in the supplementary
planning document which states allocated
parking for occupiers of dwellings
should be within the cartilage of the
site and non-allocated which could
include on street intended to provide
additional scope for visitor parking
the guidance is supported by the town's
emerging neighbourhood plan which
highlights the current concerns with off
street parking particularly in the
conservation area
it is noted in the section under the
highways massachusetts party in the
committee report
that it says among publicly
sometimes is well served by circle and
walking facilities as well as public
power parking
we wouldn't point out that the council
has an outstanding issue with struck for
district council with regarding to
resident parking in wood street car park
prior to the code of 19 outbreak we were
in discussion with stratfor district
council regarding car parking
issue to residents who are not having
parking facilities in their nearby homes
used wood street problems
at present while palestine is free it's
restricted to 24 hours parking and the
matter of residence monthly is still to
be resolved
we note that following a request for
on-street parking survey by highway a
number of spaces were identified within
walking distance of the site
and therefore removing their original
objection but would ask the committee to
take into account that it doesn't
indicate a large capacity and the
proposal is likely to make it more
difficult
to depart their vehicles finally the
town council recognizes however the
parking issue could be resolved by
reducing the post building to one
dwelling with integral of street parking
should the developer wish to consider
his position thank you
thank you very much thank you um
i have a question from uh councillor
kettle
um yes thank you councillor go ahead mr
chairman
um
in your response uh you're suggesting
um the application
instagram first conservation officer
could you um
comment would you would you expect to
see the conservation coming back with or
you know why
um i'm going to be taking you honest
one um
i have taken over this case at the last
minute um and as far as i know we put a
request in for a response from the
conservation officer as we would do with
any uh development within the
conservation area to see what the
conservation officer's views were on the
building
um i'd like to ask you a question um
councillor um was there any consultation
between the developer and uh the town
council on this
yes there was we did meet with the
developer at one of our um planning
meetings and we did talk to him and we
did raise our concerns about the uh
street parking and we did suggest to him
that should it be um if it was a one
single building then obviously that
would be looked on more favoritely
because there'd be parking um so we did
talk at lantern about the lack of
parking on that site
are there
any more questions for
the counsellor
no
thank thank you very much thank you um
thank you
right we have our next uh speaker is uh
adam welsh
objecting and i believe it's david
minnie as well um you've got three
minutes between you
just before you just before you move on
and we don't have adam welsh with us
so we've been in touch with mr minnie
and told him that he can take the time
um
we had suggested that they sorry
and i missed all that i'm so sorry could
you repeat that
sorry yes um
mr welsh had registered first but we've
sent numerous emails and he's not
responded to any of our emails so
he suggests that mr minnie takes the
three minutes if he wants it because we
just can't that he didn't give us a
telephone number and we've not been able
to get hold of him despite numerous
emails
okay so so sorry and so it's just mr
welsh yes mr minnie is it is that in the
meeting yes i'm so sorry uh
mr david minnie
can you hear us
is
is david minnie there
is mr minnie you just need to press star
6 to unmute
thanks for joining us um okay thank you
hello
um you have
three minutes thank you and can you
please stay on for any questions thank
you
thank you i'm speaking on behalf of my
mother mrs julie minnie who lives next
door to the poho's site and also mr alan
wright who lives opposite the site
my mother who has lived there since 1960
visiting my disabled brother who's
epileptic
he sleeps downstairs and because of his
disablement
all you'll be looking at is a side wall
and the light into the kitchen into the
bedroom is going to be
really impacted
so why i'm objecting to these these are
the reasons why
there is no other house in the street
that is 2.5 storage high
there is a block of flats but when they
were adequate parking was supplied
and they wasn't overlooking all the
properties
0.2
the town council i believe bought a rule
in but every new property built there
should be two parking
spots supplied to have your new house
built
the third point is mr wright has asked
me to raise
is
he's living opposite the proposed site
and basically is right of light to his
windows he's going to be severely
impacted and the eight windows facing
onto his windows and his bedroom and his
bedroom windows
they're gonna be able to be seen through
so his privacy is severely impacted as
well as his light and so is
how a right of light as powers could be
impacted point four
is that a one way it's a one-way narrow
lane
if there's cars parked one side of the
lane to go to the shops which happens
all the time because there's a regular
traffic warden that comes down the area
and buxom
and there are
the hours opposite
i've got unloading shopping or anything
then the road is going to be blocked and
that's very concerning to my mother my
brother and mr right because they have
severe
health issues and my brothers are severe
epileptic so ambulances are needed quite
frequently
um we all agree that something needs to
be built on the site but a bungalow or
one bedroom house with adequate parking
will be more suitable
um i thank you for listening to listen
from listening to me on this matter
thank you mr
minnie now are the
any questions
for mr minnie
does anybody have any questions
no
thank you mr minnie thank you oh oh
we've got so council sorry counselor
kettle
you have to unmute
unmute
thank you mr chairman
um mr milly you you mentioned um
that i think um
your neighbor is it your mother's
neighbor lives immediately opposite the
house is that right
yeah but cars still park on there to go
to the shops and they park outside
gentlemen's house some of the time by
most of the time because the shop the
first shop by the gentleman's house i'm
talking about is a bone shop and people
put their blue badge on there to park
and basically they're allowed to park
there because they've got a blue badge
so people have to come up the curb and
we've had our wall knock down seven
years ago by a car coming up the curb
um doing damage to our wall
so because it's they've got a blue badge
and they park on the alarms you can't
stop them because they go in there for
treatment for their backs or their hips
or
whatever pain they're in
okay and and your mother lives
in the in the cottage immediately as
you're looking at the hall from the road
on the right is that right that's right
there since 1966
and
you know
thank you very much um and you mentioned
um
ambulances being called out was that on
behalf your mother or your neighbor
um
my mother my mother's had an ambulance
five times in the past 18 months and my
brothers have ambulance about six times
in the past 12 months because he's a
severe epileptic and they've had
they've even had trouble getting down
the lane and i want a cage and they have
to back up which took an extra 15
minutes now somebody don't have an
epileptic fit i'm not being funny but
time can be crucial they can call up the
tongs
thank you very much thank you for that
no problem thank you
thank you councillor kettle uh any more
questions for um mr minnie
no no more questions or thank you thank
you mr mini thank you very much thank
you for your time thank you
thank you
before you move on any further we have
not got the applicant either oh gosh
so
we've sent emails and we've asked made
requests and they've not come back to us
and they've
they asked to speak initially but
they've not come back to us with the
details so unfortunately
we'll have to
move on
thank you anne um we will then move on
to the um
clarification then thank you
um
questions for joe
oh sorry i'm so sorry
i forgot the ward member how could i do
that
who who is the ward member
some young chap i think
sorry andy i'm so sorry
over here you have five minutes do you i
i suppose you know that thank you uh
council mills thank you uh fellow
councillors
yes obviously it's very disappointing
you're not able to ask the applicant for
some of these clarifications about his
uh application to build two
flats uh two houses two-bedroom in an
area whilst i agree with the
principle of development for
uh us
per mr brooks
uh pricey on page 18
i will be opposing asking you to refuse
this application
um
as uh council we've mentioned past if
it's not quite right it's wrong
uh and i think this is not quite right
the town council rightly polite pointed
out that
the
under our spd
a two bedroom house should have at least
two parking spaces
so in this case
two times two bedroom houses we should
have four off street parking spaces
and baron's size of the plot it should
not be beyond the width of anybody to
design at least some parking spaces to
make a token effort towards off street
parking
the only reason in my opinion is that i
haven't put them on is because they
could make more profit
with uh i uh with properties that are
bigger and didn't have any parking
spaces so i i think that is very poor
and something needs to be addressed
and the real reason why it's concerning
is
that southam we have got a free car park
uh and councillor john was right that
one of the councillors on sales on town
council actually received a parking
ticket for parking in wall street car
park with 24 for 24 hours it's not a
24-hour car park
and the concern about that is uh
stathamtown center
he's been suffering recently for various
different reasons and he's been
exacerbated by covid19
the market that was successful
won't be reopening
preen's the health and beauty shop which
i go regularly to have my hair dyed as
you can tell and my nails cut um well
obviously
has gone out of business as well
probably because i haven't been getting
there somewhere because my roots are
coming through
um but personally it's
we do need to make sure
that when people come into town there
are spaces to park
and off street parking in wood street is
one of the benefits that the residents
have saved and we're appreciative of
stratfor district council report it's
right by the toilets it's it's an ideal
place
and if these parking spaces are taken up
by residents
uh because they've moved into a property
where the developer couldn't be bothered
to put any parking spaces off street
parking spaces in
that is not very good for the
regeneration of the town center in satan
uh look which is like many other ten
centers in workshop taken a great hit
since covid
so
if people want to come and park and
there's no parking spaces they'll go
somewhere else
um
it's also mentions in the report that a
lot of places these days because it's
sustainable so them has got a decent bus
service where that's not true we have to
change several buses to get
to get to different places and to go
into hospital to warwick in particular
is a nightmare and university helps or
comes in workshop
the shops in the town center very small
again
we've lost that one the fruit food shop
cycle and stores as you saw earlier it
had gone from that garish green icon
stores into a funeral parlor so they
won't be selling much food there so if
people want to do some shopping
uh there's this one very small co-op
but there's a big
a bigger test goes on the industrial
site which is a really good way to walk
so again you need a car to go there so
sustainability point of view uh from you
definitely need a car living in southam
so that's why the we do need off street
parking spaces um
again to ensure the vitality of the time
there's been several
um reasons for objection on page 18. so
page 17 and i'll go through some of them
um i'll see the historical importance of
the huts which i agree but unfortunately
they have run into disrepair
so i agree there's something should be
done on that site but this should be two
two bedroom houses this this is not
right
parking there's 30 seconds chairman
parking is the main concern over the
dominance of the plot size yes it's over
developed because i can't get enough
parking spaces on uh lack of public
parking blocking the public highway it's
a narrow one there and we've got shops
there as well so again people park there
we need to make sure people can use the
shops the poodle parlor and the buck
place um so again we need to make sure
that the space is available
harm to the character of the
conservation area but potentially over
very narrow to character
and overshadowing
so lots i'm going sad to see a lot of
human assets but i i can understand that
so basically
i do not support this application ask
you to refuse it thank you
thank you councillor crump um
was it john fielding are you wanting to
ask a question
no
yes
oh thank you john the man you keep
quoting is apparently in south well
having counting camels on the beach
with the heat but anyway there you go
um i'm sorry to hear you you've got loss
of your poodle parlor um
what is the
requirement for small units in southam
one of the things that the district are
trying to get is smaller units
surely these would be attractive
to what is required
in the in in southam
um
[Music]
we've got as you know we've had 1100
plus houses sou-1 sou-2 and sou-3
which have got 236 165 and 535 houses
respectively plus um a couple um
hayfield
um can we talk about the application um
yeah
i'm sorry i'm so sorry but say can we
talk about the application and i'm just
building up to it okay so mills
the fact that we've had significant
amounts of houses of all sizes of one
two
three four five bedroom houses so we're
not particularly short of uh units of
any size um in fact um
if anything
we would be sure to bungalows
and the hayfield home ones that got
approved
one of the reasons got it approved was
it had six bungalows that eventually
went to five but it had six bungalows
because we've got a shorter one so a
bungalow there are bungalows in the
vicinity would be more appropriate so
um a long-winded answer but hopefully
you've got it got the answer
thank you thank you thank you councillor
um
are there any other questions for
uh it's uh councillor kettle
councillor kettle
yeah thank you thank you mr chairman um
two questions mr crump
council donald trump
um one is you mentioned uh at the
beginning of your response about the
historical
um importance of the hubs to southern
village
um and reading through the report it
these date back to 1919 and therefore do
have
um
some quite significant historical
reference given that last year we
celebrated the or 18 months ago we
celebrated the um 100th anniversary of
the end of the second of the world war
one
um
if it is of
relevance to to the town and the
um
and yourself as ward remember
um is there any way that the property
could be accommodated elsewhere in
southam given it was moved originally
from belgium to southern could it move
be moved from southern locally which
would ensure the historical
uh bit was retained
um
we are supposed to be talking about this
application we seem to have wandered off
the subject uh with the last couple of
speakers so is it possible if we can get
back to the actual application
please
um well okay mr nash i was just asking
you know given the historical importance
that the
council has referred to whether there's
any way of mitigating that the second
issue
is
if you were to substitute a bungalow
for what is currently proposed
um
the planning officer
mr brooke has has identified that
there is a step change from the house on
the left
to this application to the smaller
houses on the right and therefore there
is a you know
a flow what you'd be by putting a
bungalow in how would you feel that was
affect the street scene compared to what
mr brooke has already
commented on
can we actually refer can we actually go
back to the actual application please
i'm not going to reference the type of
dwelling in that case there's any in
that case thank you mesa has anybody got
any questions
for councillor crump
and can you put it in the chat bar
please instead of waving
away
no
thank you councillor crump
thank you very much i'll go to the
beauty parlor now yeah i think you need
it
um
right then sorry it's points of
clarification now um
do you know
anybody got any questions uh
john john fiore
you're muted
john and apologies for the language
uh if you heard it um
the
the the creative design of the property
could it if um
i'm not happy with it um because you
can't get the vehicles off the road
but has the applicant ever discussed
with you moving the properties back
so that he could put parking on the
front
and having less garden at the rear
um
there has been many amendments to this
application to be honest to try and get
it into a workable solution uh that was
kind of sore
all i can do is make suggestions to the
applicant the applicant went off and did
a parking survey which
is referenced in my report and available
online
um if he did do that it would affect the
immunity spaces to the rear so i can't
really comment on the design without
seeing
a new application very much or
significant amendments
so
it was discussed but at no point was uh
was a proposal put forward like that so
i could only assess what is in front of
me
thank you
more questions for clarification could i
ask one joe please
um
actually something that um uh david
mitty mentioned and i was going to do
that
um
this question of
of uh off street parking
i i just had it in my mind that we when
we had a new build we had to supply it
off street parking is that is that not
correct
it's not technically correct no sorry uh
it basically the spd
highlights the
highlights that they can be situated
based on where off street parking is not
a suitable or viable solution also you
have to appreciate there is policies
within the core strategy that is trying
to promote sustainable travel and by
trying to promote sustainable travel at
times you don't want to keep putting in
more and more parking you want to kind
of force people to do the bus services
to walk to cycle in the spd moreover
though which is pretty much what we base
this assessment on it is stated if car
free development is proposed they have
to demonstrate sufficiently
why off street parking
can be accommodated elsewhere
what the applicant did was went back and
did a parking survey and i appreciate
counselor comes comments regarding the
uh parking
uh public car park but actually in the
parking survey it was referenced craven
lane penndot street and stowe drive
which is in the near vicinity of the
site when they did that they did a thing
called the lambeth method which is
referenced in my report
and they undertook the survey from that
and decided actually in the near
vicinity of the site there is sufficient
parking on further on that we kept
consulting highways who deal with
highway safety and also parking
standards to a degree admittedly um and
they've raised no ejection from the new
parking survey
goodness
sorry guys okay
no
you can't now thanks um i was messing
about my
micro um
just
lots of things actually um
looking around the lesser objection um
harm to the character of the aryan
conservation era can can you
tell me again how far how far we're in
the conservation area with this uh
with this proposed development we're
we're we're within the conservation area
is part of the heart of the company i
mean the whole concert it'd be unfair
for me to say one conservation area is
more important than the other it is in
the conservation area okay simple as
that
thank you very much
and
oh i think that is that question from
the council kettle
um that's general i think you've asked
the question it was relating to parking
again okay
thank you perhaps i could just ask the
parking immediately to the left of the
property and behind the property
that would all be retained but that is
the use of the flats is that correct
fundamentally yes
it's not part of this application it's
not in the red line boundary so
technically that is not allowed to be
parking in that area for these two
dwellings they are permitted for the
other occupation of the residents around
that area
just sorry mr i'm going to follow that
up um if i may
um the
one of the speakers referred to uh
accessed by emergency services and
specifically relating to an ambulance
um
has been any response from um
either fire and rescue or the
is a very good point i just double
checked uh i did consult with them but i
didn't receive a response uh wc highways
are also meant to do that assessment
make sure emergency vehicles get in and
out of the area
um so that's why we still went with
approval i will admit it i didn't
receive a response from wc fire and
rescue
thank you very much thank you
any more questions for
joe
or clarification
no
right we um we can actually go to the
debate
um who would like to start
oh
well okay
i'll start it then as mr chairman
for this uh item um
yes i was just a bit concerned uh about
this um
not offering you know off street parking
i i i know what you're saying joe um
about this is not the case but whenever
we look at a new build no matter where
we always insist on off street parking
um i mean andy crump has
said it's not quite sustainable you do
need a car and sell them so uh
i think they will need a car
um it's just a bit concerned about it at
the moment so uh i'll listen to uh or
hear what other people are saying thank
trevor you
trevor can you hear me can you can you
unmute
uh yes i can now there you are
um
i've listened to the
information that's been put forward and
the statements that have been made
and i come back to what uh the officer
and his colleagues have concluded
the issue of parking
uh has been considered in full and the
officer has stated in his report the
policy
cs26 is complied with
the design of the properties seems to me
to be consistent with the surrounding
buildings it's not it's not
it's not disproportionate in any way
that i can uh appreciate
the the structure
that
is is being replaced is is a derelict
and apparently unloved
wooden building which has uh clearly
outlived its usefulness
this this proposal will provide
uh homes for
anything up to four people
uh
i i don't see
any sound planning reason
that the the officer hasn't considered
uh that would stop me from saying i am
prepared to accept the officer's
recommendation
thank you siva thank you very much uh
anybody um can you please use the chat i
have
what happened i got speaking oh yes
thank you sorry john you're quite right
i jumped the queue i know i'm very upset
about it too i can see um
i'm going to go against
and go for refuse
it's
it's not within the street scene
it's too cramped
it's too near the road and should be
moved back to get parking on i know
that's
talking about redesign which is not what
we're looking at as per this applique
application
but all in all under cs
5 cs 9
and possibly under cs10
um as10
there are a lot of
areas within those
core strategy things that
um this design and this concept goes
against
um
and i'm totally
and i propose that we refuse it
thank you john thank you
um
now council kettle
i'll just screw part of what council
fielding has said
um and i'm sorry to disagree with um
our
normal chairman not the current chairman
isn't doing a great job
um
that um there is a consistency that mr
brooke has identified between the
property on the left at
probably about three stories these are
two and a half and the ones on the right
two stories
um so
um
he has emphasized the need that the
materials must match very closely the
existing properties which again would
ensure that there would be a consistency
between the properties running from left
to right
and therefore
i think the officer has dealt with that
appropriately
um
i do have
a problem with
um
ces 26
um and more importantly
with spd
uh park private
parking standards residential
where it says the residential parking
stand is applied to all
a provision should be normally made
within the cartilage of properties in
shared parking areas or a combination of
the two
the standards apply equally to
affordable market housing
so
this has been picked up and and
the town council
again that isn't i mean it recognized a
historical background for properties but
it doesn't appear to be keen to take
them on
um there are other facilities available
um in the nearby grange hall
um and therefore we will be losing a
1919 relic
there's very little um
support for to take for maintaining that
so it all goes down to the parking and
it also you know therefore goes down to
um whether
this can be as defined and we are now
looking as mr nashville but pleased to
hear me say in this application
um whether this is sustainable and my
view is if you cannot park a car and mr
crump made it quite clear sorry
councillor crump
that there is minimal
shopping
in central town
south of them now compared to what they
used to be there used to be budgets on
the left it used to be the acorn store
and other
opportunities to shop now
bulk of the shopping is done
in the ashetown tescos
and therefore
um
that is where the problem about cars
um and where they're going to park
arises and i'm very familiar with since
i mean it's nearly my neighboring ward
and there is parking in the high street
but that is always cool
um and therefore what we're proposing is
putting two more residential units four
more vehicles into an area
um and i just do not understand where
these vehicles are going to go so i
absolutely concur with everything mr
brooke has said and he's put it
succinctly and accurately
except for
not cs26
specifically
but our spd on parking that was adopted
i think in july 2019 so it is a relevant
and update document
um and therefore i get to listen to what
people have to say
but that is where i have a sticking
point and going back to council crump
if it isn't right it's not right and if
it's not right we need to
give the outcome an opportunity to
revisit it by submitting a revised
application so that's what my thinking
is at the moment
thank you chair
i always have reservations about
off street parking
and the more this is accepted the worse
the situation is going to get
so i would
refuse this application and one house
would be enough with off street parking
thank you
thank you very much
uh
is anybody else
want to
enter the debate
no
well
council kettle you're waving your arm to
me
sorry i should have done it through the
notes i apologize i'm just going to
cs26 parking standards parking
perversion will reflect local
circumstances and regard the need to
promote sustainable transport options
now we've got no electric part electric
charging on these sites because
people can't park up on site so that's
not sustainable but i think this local
circumstance issue is fundamental
to this application and therefore
i am beginning to to to harden on on
that view again i'll listen to other
views
okay thank you right um now we've had um
we've
don't forget i can see that mesa yeah
now uh trevor you um
did you you want to propose
to accept this uh to grant this
application
reviews in front of you
sponsored by proposed by council of
fielding i think your correct course of
action is to ask for a second for that
proposal
before i may uh councillor faring
actually put in the chat to speak yeah
oh sorry i'm so sorry you're right i'm
sorry bill
no that's okay thank you chairman um
i'm always wary of any any sort of
housing that
says that they can manage without a car
i really think the um
the idea of producing houses with no
parking to make people use public
transport
i think it's always a bit pie in this
guy and a bit fanciful
i think i'm
a bit in the real world when it comes to
especially living in a village myself
as to how much you have to use motor
cars
and uh
councillor crumps already said that
buses aren't all what they seem to be in
uh
inside them
and so
i would say that
without a parking provision
um i would recommend refuse the
application
thank you thank you thank you bill thank
you
um
do
um can we get tracy to sum this up
before the proposals
please happily chairman yes i'm here
listening to all the debate and and
making notes so uh thank you for
everyone's contributions there i
appreciate the the complexities the
proposal gives um certainly the
application's been with us um you'll see
from its age for quite some time and
it's gone through quite a lot of
amendments as we've tried to explore
with the applicant some some solutions
to some of the constraints the site
offers
and what joe's presented in terms of the
approved plans as you've spoken about is
is a design which reflects the uh the
changing levels across the site uh but
also some of the taller buildings which
are within the street scene both were on
the road it fronts onto but also the the
taller development to the rear so we
feel in terms of uh design and sighting
that the the character of the
development that uh
that is in front of you for determining
uh determination tonight is is one that
could be supported in street scene and
design terms
clearly there's a lot of debate about
parking
and quite a lot of the debate has
extended beyond the needs of this
particular application and talked maybe
about the wider problems as may be
perceived in in southam
but nevertheless it only falls on this
applicant to address the parking issues
which are arising from his particular
proposal and as the spd allows he's gone
down the route of assessing local
parking need with uh with a parking
survey
and on what the report also talks about
but which hasn't really been debated by
uh uh by members so far is is
recognizing that the local circumstance
of this particular site is a community
hall which already has no car parking
um so in essence that is the local
circumstance which the developer is is
reflecting um the the um the community
hall at the moment has no parking and
its users
potentially um at peak times would have
been parking um throughout the
surrounding roads
um
so in essence in that sense there is
there is no change to the uh the absence
of parking compared to the current use
of the site and that is i'm sure
something which has guided the the
developers uh insistence on
putting forward a scheme which which has
no parking and as officers we would have
to acknowledge as we have done in the
report that
the car parking uh issues which are like
likely to arise from two dwellings in
our view is not going to be worse than
the parking issues that could have
arisen from the historical use of the
site so again that's another plank of
that that sort of sustainability a local
circumstance of the proposal which which
we feels uh
supports our recommendation of approval
for the scheme overall
thank you tracy thank you very much um
right
thank you um
right we had a proposal from um trevor
harvey uh do we have a secretary from
john fielding
john can you hear me john
john
can you unmute please
i can hear you yeah my my comment
basically is when it was a community
hall it was probably used john we're
going to we're going to the we're going
to the vote yeah okay now i'm i'm
prepared
still prepared to propose refusal
are you seconding
trevor's
no no i'm not sick trevor wants to
approve it
i want to refuse it i'm so sorry i
thought you wanted to approve i'm so
sorry
okay if i interrupt uh councillor harvey
didn't propose he was in support of the
recommendation but he didn't actually
propose okay right i apologize for that
i apologize for that um
well then who would like to make a
propose a recommendation on this to
grant
um
so that will be trevor harvey
seconded by
so we don't have a seconder
but thank you very much um
right
they said now we we go to the vote on
this now about
uh sorry chair no there's no second
there so it's now just a clean sheet
again and then it's up to the council to
decide what they want to do right
okay then
sorry sorry
counselor kevin you're waving your hand
uh mr chairman
so can you hear me
we had we had a proposal from mr field
council fielding
to refuse the application
which were waiting to see if there's a
seconder
so
that is where we currently stand mr
harvey did indicate as mr nash has said
council harvey did
indicate he will he was involved the
application but he didn't put a proposal
forward so the only proposal we have is
mr fieldings and we have but we don't
have a second as of yet
you're on mutual
you're on youtube do we have a second of
full counsellor fielding i will second
okay thank you councillor and your
seraphin thank you very much
um right we do need to go to the vote on
this then no joe we need some reasons
first all right okay
reasons for refusal for this
um
i i i'm sorry to keep coming back to
this uh question of um off street
parking uh i know they've had this
survey and i listened to tracy was
saying it to joe
um but whenever
we look at a new build we always insist
on this of
that if not here too it won if not two
two spaces so uh
that that is my problem at the moment um
yeah
i mean is it out of keeping is it in the
uh because of this um
conservation area we have a bit of a
mishmash down there haven't we
go
council kettle
um
mr chairman i think the
the principal um i think members have
expressed a number of different views
um both for and against the design
um it would seem to me that the majority
view that i've heard
from members is about the lack of um
appropriate parking facilities now i
know that's the view i took so i don't
wish to um overall any other member of
this committee
but if that's helpful it would be
that whilst there has been a parking
survey carried out
um the parking provision does not meet
um
cs26
are um
subsection 6c
parking standards
um it doesn't meet
um
i'm trying to find the next one which is
the provision of
um
i'm looking for help here
electronic charging for vehicles well
yeah
sorry chris um
i'm sort of not clutching straws putting
ideas forward
not sustainable this
anybody buys a a house they've usually
got a car that's without doubt
um
and we're not providing this
church just to uh restrict my comments
on the last application
uh you know if uh
applicants take this forward uh if the
ca at the committee are mindful to
refuse
that we do need to come up with solid
planning three i agree mesa i i agree
well foreign that's what i was trying to
identify in cs26 okay uh that is non-con
non-compliant with with c uh paragraph c
and also it's not compliant
with the s our district council's spd
um namely parking standards residential
which identifies should be a provision
of one or two dwelling
units should have been made within the
curtains of the properties
um
so
you know we we've got we've got two
reasons the spd and cs26
uh is that is that something we can go
is that something we can go with joe
shall i join in at this point again um
effectively um
what members again are are articulating
our concerns about parking um or the
absence of parking um so i really think
by the sounds of it that is one reason
for refusal it's the lack of parking uh
set out as in in
core strategy policy and the sdp rather
than two separate um car parking uh
related reasons for refusal so by the
sound of it you're articulating one
reason for refusal for officers in
relation to lack of knocking
right i don't know what the reason that
um anyone has articulated so far okay um
i think john wants to say something john
well i did quote when we were talking
about it
cs9
um
to do with visual impact and also design
which i recognize either keeping with
the neighboring properties um
i got it wrong wrong cs6
cs9 i also referred to cx-5
which was again its townscape and visual
site of the landscape um
i'll find it cs9 in a minute
um
i didn't put it down as well it's it's
not a sensitive design
in the area where you've got
a grade one or is it grade two listed
buildings
i don't look at it as distinctive
um is it environmentally sustainable no
because you've got no electrical power
points there
um and it doesn't meet some
energy efficiency that we were talking
about that's it that's a condition uh
tracy you wanted to come in again
tracy did you want to come in again
thank you chairman well um i think um
that's that's trying to broaden um uh
the concerns in relation to design and
impact on on the street scene um i think
members will need to indicate to
officers if that's a commonly held view
amongst you that you want to endorse
that as a collectively as a reason for
refusal uh at the moment i'm picking up
on the collective concern about lack of
parking um so uh perhaps chairman if you
just need to clarify with your your
fellow members yes they're all endorsing
more than just car car
absolutely yeah i think we we've got to
have we we've got to perform in the car
parking um
does this fit in with street scene um
when i i drove down there i could oh
gosh i'm going back to car park here to
see the other houses had you know
facilities
um
i'm back to club parking now so um
it it will be different that's for sure
to the other um
the other properties
um this is for sure
okay you you can go with the single
reason for refusal if you wish members
if that's the only one that you have a
general collective view i just worry
about
um
i think we've got a i think we've got to
come up with something else i'm
struggling to be honest um
which is not good uh a street scene
i mean
no
no mr challenge can i speak
sure
go ahead um
i think mr brooke has done a very good
job in in comparing the street scene and
how it fits in i said that earlier on
um mrs humphries has quite clearly said
there can be one reason for refusal and
what we know from experience from
comments we've had on many previous
occasions
that if one tries to flush out
a
handful of planning reasons for refusal
um and that we
some of those are weak
then it tends to enhance the ability
of
a
and subsequent appeal
successful
here we have an sbd
and i see a core strategy policy
about parking provision
um
and most of us have expressed concern
about parkinson's vision we also do not
have the sustainable energy of things
that we assist in almost every other
application which our house has to have
an ability to recharge an electric
vehicle
so that is the only other bit
that i believe we can we can talk about
i really believe mr brooke has made very
clear in his summation that this fits in
this in the in the street scene because
whilst council trump is not happy with
it and the immediate neighbors are
worried about overlooking mr brooke has
carried out the technical test to ensure
whether it complies
so
um
in terms of visual impact i think if
we're going to go down design of
distinctiveness we need to reopen the
debate and i'm not i don't think that is
something which we have unanimity on
what we do have unanimously all the way
through is this does not have on-site
parking
um it does and it doesn't have the
ability to recharge and therefore
doesn't comply particularly with our
local climate change position
therefore why not limit it to those two
items which is quite clear it is a it is
a we've seen many occasions when one
policy and its failure to comply with
that is sufficient to refuse an
application
and i believe on this situation we've
heard from councillor crump and if we
ignore the issues about
what
shops have come and gone mr crump was
quite comfortable quite clear that there
is not capacity inside them for parking
elsewhere and therefore parking
should be on site which complies with
cs26 and the spd end the story
thank you okay um
members of the committee are we
happy to go with that i know that trevor
harvey is uh
he looked like he thought originally
chairman i'm sorry councillor fleming
has asked to comment
no thank you very much sir councillor
kettles covered exactly what i was going
to say so
i'm more than happy just to to leave it
at that thank you
right so
um do we have a proposal counselor
kettle
council kettle
i'm happy to propose but the council of
fielding has proposed but i'm not sure
and my suggestion is and it's up to
those two
to indicate where they're happy with
those reasons for refusal should be
limited to
those those two points lack of
non-compliance with the spd on climate
change and but more importantly the spd
on parking and cs26
yeah
okay
wow
right
we can go to the boat on this can we
um uh as we
unfortunately didn't have the applicant
here to say anything but uh anyway
so we go to the vote to
refuse this application
yeah
can you
yes
i can
um
can we start with yourself then chairman
uh
yes uh council mills refused this
application
so for refusal or reflection
harvey against
thank you councillor mr sarafin
and central
seraphine for refusal
this application
thank you and councillor kettle council
kettle for for
the proposal
thank you that's five for the refusal
and one against chairman
so we have
uh
a vote on this to refuse this
application yes
refuse application
thank you
chairman
as per the previous item we would uh
draft the two reasons for refusal for
the two reasons you've given us and um
issue them in consultation with the
chairman which in this instance would be
yourself
okay
sorry check i'll just clarify you need
to actually confirm that the council has
resolved to refuse
application
whatever the application number is
and uh adding the additions that trace
you just said that so that you can
actually clarify the reasons for refusal
okay
um
we've chosen to refuse application
19 oblique
03.442 oblique ful
um
on the reasons
given
yeah subject to clarification by youtube
um
and i might just say the council
resolved to refuse yes they have
resolved refuse yeah
back in yeah like five or ten minutes
and oh we
will take five but if we get in three
we'll let you know okay thanks thank you
i'm back on
thank you you just give us a couple of
mins so we can get the speed
thanks
german speakers in the meeting now so
we're ready to go when you are
thank you um you got my picture oh okay
can you say me or not
not yet but just give us a second and
you'll be there yep
brilliant
right thank you for that thank you again
to the mills for
you appreciate the juggling between chat
and
speakers lists and members coming in
it's it's um it's an interesting
challenge isn't it i think
and well done
it certainly is
all right we'll move on to our next item
which is twenty slash zero zero five
zero zero slash f ul land off burley
roads knitter field change of use of
land from redundant airfield to storage
stroke distribution class v8 purposes
retrospective and
which is our presenting officer thank
you stuart
thank you chairman good evening
everybody can i just confirm that
everybody can see my screen before i
start and hear me
yes yes
perfect yes yes we can thank you
uh thank you good evening this proposal
is seeking retrospective full planning
permission for a change of use of the
land from a disused airfield to storage
distribution use under pollus under
class b8
the application site is an area of open
countryside outside of the built-up area
boundaries of nearby snitterfield and
barely as indicated by the black dots
here on this plan
here we see the application sites
outlined in red
the site is completely washed over by
the west midlands green belt
in addition to being within a designated
arden special landscape area
here we now see a satellite image of the
site uh
signified by the arrow with my cursor
here and here
here we now have the proposed uh site
layout plan uh put forward by the
applicants uh detailing the arrangement
of various uh building materials uh one
can also see there is some existing
vegetation that lines the site to the
west here in addition there is some
proposed new planting proposed by the
applicants uh fronting the public
highway here
members are reminded that whilst this is
obviously titled it's a proposed cycle
out plan this is a retrospective
application and all of this is currently
in situ as we speak this evening
we now have some photos of the scythe
itself
um here we see um
here we are stood on the site looking
north eastwards um towards barely road
uh here and you can see the mature trees
thereof that line the highway
again um here we are now stood in the
same position looking southwards
um
one can see uh there are numerous
container bags as you saw in your
previous photo here
um container bags uh wooden pallets uh
bricks that aren't in container bags and
other paraphernalia for a storage uh use
uh we now then have again it's the same
photo looking southwards um you can see
container bags
uh you can see in some instances i've
got more photos a lot of them are also
double stacked i either there can be
literally double in height
um you can also then look southwards and
see the wider open countryside character
further afield
uh here we see uh more instances of the
bricks uh not in um bags again we're
looking
northwards uh in this instance
um
[Music]
next slide here we're in our stood plum
center of the site uh again looking
southwards um in amongst some brags um
both single and double here another
paraphernalia you can see right here
there is a um
a metal storage container
approximately four meters in height
um this was found on on site visits um
you will note that it's not on your
proposed site layout plan but it is was
there in situ at the time of office site
visits
um finally here we're looking on the
access the narrower access track
um looking
south eastwards approaching the various
building materials that are tucked in
just behind here
in summary as is detailed in the
conclusion on page 36-38 of your gender
patch this development is defined as
inappropriate development in the green
belt where very special circumstances
are needed to demonstrate to clearly
demonstrate and outweigh the harm its
officers view that there are no vscs
either individually or commutatively
that sufficiently overcome this
identified harm to the greenbelt and the
substantial harm on loss of openness
in addition to greenbelt objections
there are then subsequently uh
objections in principle under policy
as10 so that allow for some business
development in open countryside
locations
and thirdly uh there is also found to be
a conflict with the special qualities of
the arden special landscape area which
um has a very intrinsic value
as to what should be uh
what what development should be approved
there
uh chairman please refer to your update
sheet um there are details there of two
technical questions that were asked by
council harvey uh last friday and were
addressed by myself on monday
um chairman the recommendation is to
refuse this application for the reason
set out on pages 38 of your agenda thank
you
thank you stuart and hopefully
everybody's read the
update shoot as well we're going to move
on to our first speaker which is council
corrin elliott of smithfield parish
council are you with us cancer elliott
can you hear me we can thank you
chancellor okay
you've got three minutes we'll give you
a warning with 30 seconds and please
stay on the line for any questions far
away when you're ready please thank you
chairman
there are several companies already
operating in the vicinity spa
environmental care plc which
incorporates gritting.com and
potholeuk.com are adjacent and
completely surrounded by a six foot high
metal security fence
also plant force and molten compact
equipment further along the access road
have all their plant hiring equipment
stored outside in a secure compound
assuming these are all operating legally
on this site
one wonders how these businesses manage
to satisfy those same policies referred
to with the open countryside and the
arden special landscape which are now
used as grounds to refuse permission for
this business
the applicant started renting his
brownfield site on 13th december 13 for
the purposes of recycling uk saw stone
he was told that this site had been used
for commercial purposes since the 70s
with no complaints and as the business
expanded he took the opportunity to
invest in it further and he bought the
land from his landlord six years later
in early 2019.
he actually assumed his use could be
continued or he would not have committed
to buy the land as such he did establish
business use under the genuine
presumption that it was lawful
in accordance with cs22 economic
economic development a flexible approach
can be taken on existing industrial
areas indeed it seems that this flexible
approach must have been taken in the
past when allowing the other businesses
on site to operate
it's also worth noting that sdc declared
a climate emergency on the 15th of july
19 and this recycling business is one
that should be supported given that all
the stone is sourced and then sold to
customers in the uk
rather than imported from abroad in
addition given the nature of the work
and the bulk of the material it is
better this is done outside of the
built-up boundary on an existing
industrial site and in open space
to mitigate any impact on the openness
of the green belt and to contribute to
carbon reductions
appropriate conditions could be attached
as councillors see fit
e.g limiting permission to the
brownfield concrete area planting
additional native hedge screening
although currently this site is not
visible from billy road and has no
residential neighbours
a combination of warsaw planting and
native tree planting on the grassed area
the use of recyclable green storage bags
as opposed to white this would allow an
existing business to continue their
activities under uninterrupted and
secure their employees jobs during these
difficult economic postcode times
the parish council hope this application
can be supported and believes that it's
flexibility within our ndp econ one and
in cs20 do to do so
and can be accommodated by cf-10
development on pram brownfield sites
thank you
thank you comes around here well within
time any questions to the parish council
please
i've got one answer elliot um
i'll say
you're not i believe your neighborhood
plan has been approved um
is that correct
yeah
yeah i thought it was um sorry we get to
hear about so many and
we'll always remember which ones which
so apologies for that and
you mentioned your ndp one can you just
explain what
um it's um it says the name for defense
suits by the local pro so
proposals
protecting and supporting existing
employment sites
and so
it's it's we think that it's it has been
established it's been established for
some time and although it might not have
been established perhaps in the legal
sense
the applicant generally thought that he
was operating legally
that's great thank you very much that's
very clear any other questions for a
parish council
yeah
um
councillor
councillor elliot um
has this site
sorry i've missed the point has this has
the site been
anything
at all uh
yes it has been disused
no as uh the the history of the site
that it's been used for commercial
purposes in the 1970s
and in the pack it does mention and give
reference to the various uses that it's
had oh i missed that okay that's lovely
thank you
right thank you sorry catch the mills my
chat came up very slowly i've i've got i
pledge for his speakers now
okay thank you chairman um just like to
ask the paris councillor um how many
jobs does this business support
um as far as i know there are two
full-time jobs and two part-time
and and obviously if this business had
to discontinue those jobs would be lost
well there would be yeah because he
wouldn't be able to he hasn't got
another fight to go to and the other
thing to note as well is that it's not
that he just rents this land he's
actually invested in it and he's bought
the land so
that would really impact on his cash
flow thank you very much thank you
kessler harvey please
um thank you chairman councillor elliot
um
would you be able to confirm that this
piece of the uh
green belt has been under concrete for
the last 70 odd years is that true
well it it was part of the airfield so
uh 70 years ago where are we 1930
i honestly couldn't say that it was
definitely there um for the wars
uh 1940 at least
that would make it 80 years thank you
very much
my math is off
definitely i mean i'm well as far as i
know it's it's been um um you know an
airfield
i'm using the second world war
catch the cattle please
thank you mr chairman
um is this site visible
um and we did there's really a
confirmation that could you confirm the
site is not visible from smithfield or
barely
uh i'm going to ask is it visible from
the main road
from the road that goes past the site
no
thank you no i did a site visit just to
check that out
yep thank you thank you
cancer failing please
as far as you're aware
counselor um
and thank you for a very
interesting comment on it all is there
any machinery or stone crushing
machinery that is on site that would
cause a disturbance to the neighbors
no when i went i didn't see any um and i
watched the way they were doing they
were in the stone and it's fairly manual
so they basically
they they take the stone from um or it
gets delivered from sites and all over
the uk and then they actually
chip off all the mortar that's on it and
that that is used for aggregate that
goes onto the roads and then the the
rest of the stone is then stacked not in
big piles actually when i went to they
they were low quite low
can i
and so i didn't see any questions i
don't think there's any machinery on
site that does that it's manual
just very brief then john please
um uh the other um
we've been talking about lorry loads and
extra extraction onto the road i take it
that there is no problems there
as far as the the villages are concerned
with heavy lorries going through them no
absolutely no problem though
thank you
thank you for your concise answers um
you are free to go
thank you
should we move on to our next speaker
which should be councillor richards
who's the ward member councillor
richards can you hear us please
council crump i can yes good evening all
right you've got five minutes if you
could fire away when you're ready and
we'll give you a warning with 30 seconds
i'm sure you know
thank you chair um so as with the
majority of applications in the green
belt there tends to be various
conflicting policies um on the one hand
we should be protecting the green belt
from urban sprawl but on the other we
should be supporting local and rural
businesses and allowing them to expand
looking specifically the policies
involved course strategy policy cs10
states exceptions to inappropriate
development in the greenbelt as
small-scale developments which meet a
housing employment or other need
identified by a local community in
accordance with policy cs10 countryside
and villages subject to it not being
harmful to the openness of the greenbelt
it also has a point b the limited
infilling or partial or complete
redevelopment of a previously developed
brownfield site whether redundant or in
continuing use excluding temporary
buildings subject again to not having a
material greater impact on the openness
of the green belt and the purpose of uh
including the land within that
within the existing development
the site is located on a portion of
smithfield airfield which by very
definition is considered a brownfield
site indeed that is supported by
national policy which classes airfields
as of brownfield land
it is clear to me from policy cs10 that
applications in the greenbelt should be
supported for small-scale development
that is further reinforced by the
partial complete redevelopment of a
previously developed brownfield site
regardless of its current use that is of
course provided that it doesn't have a
materially greater impact on the
openness of the greenbelt
it's important to note that the
application is not seeking to introduce
any new built form but simply to
formalize the land use to a b8
classification for the storage of
materials required for the continued
viability of this specialized business
ultimately the green belt considerations
appear to hinge on assessment over the
impact such a change of use could have
on the openness of the green belt in
this location
given no new built form is being
proposed it seems a stretch to suggest
that there would be a material and
therefore significant impact on the
openness of the greenbelt
the site itself already has
well-established a well-established set
of buildings for commercial industrial
and recreational use in the immediate
vicinity of the proposed development
site with at least five businesses
located within a short distance i think
the officer's report uh suggests 285
meters
this is very much an economically active
location and has been for a number of
years
looking out across rasheed policy cs
sorry as10 which states that the
following should be supported
bullet point m's small scale expansion
of an existing group of buildings for
business use excluding holiday let's
where the site is readily accessible by
means of transport other than private
car and n an extension to a business in
its established location particularly if
it would be unreasonable to expect the
business to relocate in order to expand
this application the applicant has
operated their business from this site
for some time and indeed the immediate
vicinity houses a number of businesses
as i've already outlined
look into policy cs22 of course strategy
that states that a flexible approach
will be taken to accommodating a wide
range of employment generating uses
including public and community uses on
existing industrial areas the expansion
of businesses in their existing location
will be supported subject to the scale
and type of activities involved the
location and nature of the site is
accessibility including by public
transport and the impact on the
character of the local area
policy cs10 as10 and cs22 when
considered together provide support for
this application in its current location
uh provided that it does not have a
materially larger impact on the green
belt
it's clear to me that this application
does indeed constitute a small-scale
expansion of an existing uh business in
its current location that by virtue of
there being no new built form would have
no material and therefore significant
impact on the openness of the green belt
there have been no objections locally
the application has the full support of
both the parish council and myself and i
will ask you to now consider granting
this application if you are still minded
to refuse uh due to the impact on the
illness of the green belt perhaps you
consider a condition that could be
placed on the site that storage of
materials would not exceed a specified
height perhaps two bags high
which would further minimize the limited
impact this change of use would have
thank you channel
thank you councillor richards uh any
questions for the world number please
all right let me go back on to our
wonderful system
uh
nobody's indicated so far
no
oh cancel the mills yes it just just
popped up yeah thanks mr chairman um
uh peter um
i could see the no objections or uh from
anybody but the
this site
and it backs on to the other it backs on
to the other industrial sites there
doesn't it
and we i'm just trying to establish
where this this green belt starts and
finishes because it it looks like a
brownfield site but it's a greenfield
site so
what is it is it green is it greenfield
isn't it brownfield
uh thank you councillor mills it is
brownfield because it is an airfield
part of it
it's no longer the airfield is no longer
used specifically as an airfield it has
a number of industries on it but it is
used of course by the gliding club so
there is some aviation there
uh it's washed over by the green belt
but because it is um an airfield it is
by definition a brownfield site and as i
say it's about 285 meters i think there
is an array of buildings that house a
series of commercial industrial uh units
for other business uses
right thank you thanks peter
thank you for cancer failing please
uh council richards you did refer to the
leisure activities was that
in the run-up to this site or would you
are you referring to the gliding club
um i i think i was actually reading a
specific quote and i wanted to make sure
i was full in that quote um but yes of
course there are leisure uh there is
some leisure on on site that being the
gliding club although that's some
distance away
thank you
any further questions for the ward
member
um
thank you canister richardson very clear
and concise and also
a very full response in the papers that
um
again indicates
much of what you've just said so again
have it in black and white in front of
us is very helpful as well so
thank you for that and you are free to
go
thanks very much chairman
right
we'll now move on to points of
clarification
i was trying to get to
the appropriate thing
just a question with regards to
um as10 greenbelt now i know i'm
dyslexic and i sometimes get meanings
the wrong way around but the following
forms of development in the green belt
are not inappropriate as in principle
small-scale developments which
meter housing employment or other needs
identified by the local community
small-scale extensions alteration to a
building or the replacement of an
existing building for the same use
limited in infill or
the partial or complete redevelopment of
a previously developed brownfield site
do these not cover what we are looking
at
uh thank you uh councillor i can happily
feel that question um
each and every one of these provisions
of cs10 and the core strategy have been
considered and assessed in your reports
um i know uh councillor richards has
just made reference to uh specifically
provision a um that has been assessed
materially in your committee pack in the
principal section
whilst we can be in agreement that this
just provides an employment use
um
the provision is subject to it not
having a harmful impact on openness now
that determination has been made and
it's been found that there is an
unacceptable impact on openness so
unfortunately
as it's detailed in your reports it
doesn't meet part a of cs10 i'm afraid
um nor does it meet uh parts b or c um
there's no building in play uh in
regards to part b um
so
there can't be uh that it can't meet
that provision uh and part c similarly
whilst we can agree that part of the
site's part of the site is it previously
developed land uh again the kicker is
the last sentence of that provision part
c
um subject to not having a materially
greater impact on the openness so
unfortunately um this application hasn't
met those standards
um so that's uh why we've arrived at our
determination in the as is reflected in
the report
thank you stuart uh councilman mills i
did miss you and do you want to come in
please
can't hear your counselor mills
uh no thanks mr chairman i'm okay no
thank you
yep
okay cancer cattle then council of
fleming
yeah i think we understand and
mr nash has confirmed
historically there hasn't been a
determination this is a legal use but
that's why we're looking at the planning
application
um but you're you're suggesting um
that the reason for refusal is because
it is an unacceptable development in the
green belt
um mr flaherty
um
but there isn't a technical definition
of unacceptable is there
i mean isn't that a value judgment a
qualitative
judgment and therefore there's nothing
there isn't a document that you can
point us at that says
this is a definition of unacceptable
having white bags on a bit of tarmac
so it's your view as opposed to a
definitive
there isn't a book
that says this is unacceptable is that
right
uh thank you che account
that's correct yeah there is no bona
fide uh hard and fast black and white
statement saying this is successful
developing the green belt this isn't
acceptable it is very much a judgment
call made by
this planning department uh myself as a
case officer endorsed by obviously our
managers
uh and and put to you as members uh this
evening um matters of greenville have to
be
fact and degree and and made an
assessment thereof
so
um
if we go
that is what
we're here to decide whether it is
acceptable or not acceptable take into
account that your view it is not
acceptable
for the reasons you you said but that is
for us to consider is that right
that's correct
thank you
thank you um
it's been referred to earlier on
that there are industrial buildings i
think to 200 meters plus
but when i visited the site and i
disclosed that earlier on
um it seemed to me that the two
containers
are
within about five meters of a i can't
remember what the correct word
but an industrial fence isn't it
[Music]
um i i can't corroborate the exact
meterage um there are two container
units small container units on the
proposed layout plan a picture i showed
you my presentation showed an additional
other unit that wasn't apparently on the
plan yeah it is adjacent to
an existing presumably approved
development in industrial a number of
industrial units yes that doesn't let
richard's touch upon yeah correct yeah
about 280 meters away yeah
280 meters away
but actually if if you look on if you
look on google earth
um it seems to me that the fence
securing that approved development
sits within 10 meters of the um
10 15 meters of the back of one of the
other units
would that occur
i can pull up a plan on the screen let
me just re-share my screen baby one
second i can perhaps clarify
a little bit
um
right so that's
um that's can can you see that i think
that's that's been shared now um
this is obviously the extent of the red
line this subject this application is
here
um
there are other units um outside of this
red line um which are here and
moreover
a larger density of commercial
space there separately to these
application sites so
can i just interrupt you i'm really
sorry
but if you go back to previous
strawberry the red line area
now if you go immediately north
uh and east of the driveway into the
site
yeah
that is a developed area here isn't it
because there's a security gate going
into it
um and there is a security fence that
runs all the way around that
block which where your mouse is right at
the moment
there are
there are two units um that are detailed
on this plan um you are correct
um
there i can't tell you um just the left
of this photo essentially
uh here absolutely i may have a photo in
my backup slides
um
i can't tell you counselor what's there
without going through
other plans
i couldn't tell you
what they are i don't appear to have a
photo here on the presentation
um
but they are outside the red line i
can't tell you what they are other than
um
they're outside the jurisdiction of this
application
uh yeah but the when you've just said
they're 200 meters away what i'm
suggesting is actually
um and i'm just bringing it up
on my screen um it is
at most it seems to me about
10 well i've got it on google earth
there are built properties within that
fenced area
10 less than 10 meters from the
water cappings or all of the container
units yeah i mean clarify
the 200 meter figure that's in my report
and quoted by peter richards refers to
the wider commercial area further south
uh east uh from our southwest big one
from our site not those two units that
you just referred to that but that's not
the measurement for that one
no i agree so what i'm saying is there
is an industrial development within 10
meters of
um
the two containers which form part of
this application site
whether it can constitute an industrial
development i can't speak to that i'm
afraid i don't have any photographic
evidence i can't speak to that i'm
afraid that there are two units on that
plan which are in very close proximity
to the red line whether they're in
commercial industrial use i don't know
well i mean there is that there is a
security gate going into it and there's
industrial equipment on that site isn't
that
chair can we um i think um you know
we've gone over this subject quite a lot
now can we actually now move on because
i don't think stuart has the details to
confirm
kettle is asking him yeah i'm i'm happy
happy to agree that um yeah okay
councillor fleming if you would like to
come in please
sorry i'd nearly forgotten what i was
going to ask um
the
the reference to um the effect on the
openness of the green belt
um there's no buildings and there's
nothing higher than a couple of meters
off the floor in terms of double stacked
bags um i'm not sure
from my perspective um which
what measurement you're using to say
that it's affecting the openness of the
uh the countryside that's there so is it
a bit like we were asking before
is it a subjective statement to say it's
spoiling the the openness or is there
again a rule book to say it can't be any
more than a meter higher you know
otherwise it spores the openness because
that particular thing then affects the
harm it's meant to be doing so if there
is no um
impact on the openness or the openness
it isn't affected by just two bags
stacked one on top of the other um i'm
not sure how it can
it can affect that in the long term so
that was just my question what what
actually is an effect on the openness of
the land or what is on that site that is
affecting the openness of the land
thank you thank you uh councillor uh yes
i think um
i think a term that's been used in your
reports is a proliferation of container
bags there are a sizeable number there
on officers visit
um visits plural um there are numerous
commercial paraphernalia um
that constitutes cumulatively uh what is
deemed to be by officers an unacceptable
impact on openness uh as was touched
upon earlier by question i think council
kettle asked earlier
to clarify there is no hard and fast
definition of what could be an
acceptable impact of openness and what
can't be each and every case has to be
considered its own merits and uh we've
deemed this to be an unacceptable impact
on openness
thank you sure curse the building
there is a president
can't hear you very well john we can
hear you but you're freaking out
now you can hear me
and the president created by this is
that airfields by definition
are open spaces
you can't have
um
any obstacles in the way so therefore
the tarmac
and the areas where
the dispersal units were
are by nature open
so they are therefore
uh under um as12
um open spaces and suitable for
brownfield sites a an airfield is
um as we had an argument last time we
did this one um an open a brownfield
site
with an element maybe of contamination
from aircraft or whatever were there
um
i cannot understand why
something that
has been
involved in
um commercial use which this area has
either aircraft or whatever
um no longer because would be
falls out of the bracket of brownfield
site i think that we've got to go with
as12
where it does refer to the fact that the
green belt is available
for a certain amount of commercial and
job creation
so
you're trying to say against the fleming
that
council of fielding please
i'm sorry bill went from my
i was just trying to get to get to a
question um well the question is
the president is there
are you trying to change a precedent
okay thank you
um i think i can uh i can take that
thank you councillor um i i can't say i
i wholly agree i'm afraid i think our
legal counsel has made reference to a
lawful development certificate in your
planning history section
uh that was submitted by the applicants
um
where it was found that there was uh
on
stacked in the all balanced
probabilities that there wasn't a lawful
commercial use on this site for
continuous period of 10 years uh which
is what is required for this to be a
precedent if that's if that's the word
you're going to use um
one of my colleagues has been to sites
has examined all the documents all the
satellite imagery affidavits etc and
that
lawful development certificate was
refused la in 2019 i believe so i have
to take slight objection i don't think
there is a precedent of uh commercial
use on this specific application redline
area uh that you're being asked to
assess
um
and on matters of cs10 greenbelt um
i think you and i we've already
dialogued on that on that that's been
wholly considered fully uh and it's not
been found to meet those provisions i
think it's 12 you're referring to an
astr um
john can we move on after certainly
yeah i've got
cancer harvey then i'll bring trace in
after catching the harvey and then
please uh thank you mr chairman we've
been at this particular application for
well over half an hour now can i just
put my name down be first to speak when
we get to the debate i'm keen to get
there
yeah no that's that's fine tracy if
you're yo i'm keen to get on as well i
can see everything
yeah i'm happy to uh to contribute to
questions during the debate if that
would assist you easier
yeah that's good yeah okay let's move on
to the debate now then please
obviously we've touched on a lot of
things on the questions that are virgin
on on the debate as our legal officers
pointed out
um
catch the cattle
sorry i think councilman harvey said oh
oh yeah sorry um
i was that stunned by somebody moving
this on um okay it's the harvey
thank you apologize that's all right um
i know you've got a difficult job um
i came to this uh
debate this evening with with two minds
because uh there are good arguments on
both cases on both sides of the of the
application and i think the the officer
has done a very thorough job in
defending the arguments in favor of the
green belt and hence refusal
um
on the other hand it is unusual to find
this sort of an application being
supported by both parish council and
board member in such detailed terms
um my perspective is that
uh this prop this
brownfield site accepting councillor
richard's
use of that phrase in relation to the
whole of the air fees field but this is
an area that has been under concrete for
80 years
um i cannot see that if we refuse this
application i cannot see that the green
belt is any better off as a result what
i do see
is that a business which is uh
contributing to uh recycling and hence
climate change and hence a conservation
policy and it's it's securing employment
um it i doubt whether it would be ever
used for anything else the fact that you
can't see this site from this from the
from the road
it's well hidden uh there are additional
uh precautions being uh suggested that
apply as conditions to this application
and i think we have teased out a very
important matter and that is that the
officers are entitled to their judgment
and counsellors are entitled to theirs
and there are subjective elements
involved here and they're they're big
ones and they're important ones my view
is that on balance having heard the
discussion that i would approve this
application and if you need a proposal
i'm your man
thank you councillor harvey so you're
you're trying to say just so i'm very
clear that you believe that the reasons
you mentioned are very special
circumstances that overcome the green
the green belt that washes over the area
my view my view is
that the
elements of the core strategy which uh
put an obligation
on the uh council to foster the
interests of local business in this
particular case in these particular
circumstances
outweigh the need to protection uh to
provide protection for the green belt
yep okay yep
thank you for that
right who have i got no i've got cancer
kettle
um yes i mean councillor harvey almost
rendered my speech speechless as it were
oh god
thank you
i'm not going to get away with that hang
on
um
i'm more than happy to second councillor
harvey's
uh proposal and i think the reasons are
set out clearly on page 29
um looking at specific policies involved
core strategies series 10 states a and b
um and we talk about small scale
employment we've heard it can't be seen
from from the road it can't be seen from
any any of its settlement
and therefore the impact on the the
openness of the green belt
is is difficult to understand
in particular as we have um seen and in
fact the the report on page 29 again
says
um it can be clearly seen there's
already a well-established set of
buildings commercial industrial
recreational in the immediate vicinity
of the proposed development with at
least five businesses located with a
short distance now my site visits showed
those within with less than five ten
meters of the two rather unattractive
porter cabins
um
we've got jobs we've got support from
the community we've got support under
cs10 and therefore those are the reasons
i would go against office recommendation
because it is a value judgment uh my my
view along with cancer harvey is that
there is very little impact on the
openness of the green belt on this site
thank you thanks the mills
oh thanks mr chairman yeah i mean i i
like chris i i drove onto the site and
it is well tucked away
but if we are minded to grant this i i
have to say i thought we've got to say
to them they can't stack these uh bales
too high because i could see the bales
from a distance uh they were more than
too high uh but um i agree with
everybody says there the
world member uh is passionately for it
and so is the parish council so uh
yes i support this um
application mr chairman thank you thank
you
thank you ken smith
sorry stuart
um
i'm like-minded with i wasn't i wasn't
quite certain with council harvey was
for or against but evidently he's for
the for the the the proposal rather than
refusing it um i don't see why we can't
get them to plant trees all the way
around
um along the site north south east and
west to to hide it for the future and
apart from anything else it would be
environmentally friendly going along
with our green policies that the
district council wants uh in favor of
going against the officers
and allowing that
as a
uh
for the feud for
what they're wanting it for yeah i've
got no further speakers indicating at
the moment
and i i won't be commenting um i'll
bring the planning manager to spring
into some up um
and see if there's any conditions if we
are minded to grant this application i
noticed um council of folding was
touching on landscaping and council
mills had touched on about the heights
of the uh the rule um for wanting better
fries so can you come in please
uh thank you chairman yes um obviously
we've listened to the debate and we
understand members
perspective um we've tried to present
you with a balanced report which we feel
acknowledges some of the strengths of
the application but in office's view it
also stresses what we feel to be some
fundamental deficiencies with the
proposal we've got three reasons for
refusal which we're recommending
and some of the uh
the important issues to
to be aware of when you determine the
application is is firstly that it's not
within the built-up area boundary
um it's not within a local service
village nor is it is it within the
confines of the village it is very
definitely within the green belt it's
within the open countryside um and it's
also within an area or a special
landscape character so we feel there are
three very strong reasons for refusal
here i understand that people have
described it as as an established
business
in fairness it's more accurate to say
it's an existing business but it's one
that exists without the benefit of
planning permission it's never had a
planning permission what's more it's had
a refusal of a certificate of lawful
development where insufficient uh
evidence could be submitted to
demonstrate that it had been used for
the required period in order to be then
be immune from enforcement action
so
accepting uh members right to disagree
and how they balance issues i would have
to say that officers feel that this is
quite a clear-cut case of unacceptable
development in the green belt and we do
feel that the photos also demonstrate
that the impact on the openness of the
green belt we feel is quite significant
in this case it's an extensive area of
of open storage um and
all i can
do is is endorse the recommendation that
we've put to members and that we feel
that the three reasons refusal we've set
out are uh are well judged um ones which
we uh we recommend to you
thank you
i think that members appreciate the
amount of hard work that went into this
application and the detailed knowledge
that stuart uh
showed both in his presentation and also
in his in-depth answers to
all the questions i think it has been
acknowledged is is a really good report
in front of us so uh thank you for that
i think that um members have um realized
that that um again it's been discussed
as a mention of plan imbalance and the
effect and
as long as say one one one's purse one
person's whining is another person's
poison um and
based on on
what we're hearing
uh so far um i think i think it has been
quite close and uh on on this um it's
not you know um i don't think it's
opening shop case and i think that the
the debate and discussions have i've
been pretty
pretty in depth um
i think we've had a proposal
uh and a second proposal cancer harvey
and seconded
by was it cancer kettle
uh secondly by councillor kettle to
um
[Music]
that
the for the reasons mentioned by
councillor harvey i think in particular
uh
the job protection um i think the
reasons why counts the
richards as well
that
these constitute very special
circumstances
uh
for allowing this application to be
granted
um
that's what i'm getting um
i've been prompted by mr nash um
have i explained that properly or do we
need to say more about the reasons
the very special circumstances to
overcome development and in the green
belt well i would like tracy to just
clarify those very special circumstances
please check
if you wouldn't mind
thank you chairman um
well in fellas i think it's it's it's
the chairman who's indicated what he
thinks to be the uh uh a summary of
members views as to what the very
special circumstances are that they feel
um it uh it is acceptable in the green
belt so i accept members can
entirely take a different view to uh
to officers um
but um i'm i can't suggest uh very
special circumstances to you because
clearly our officer recommendation is is
that we don't feel there are any uh
vscs
um what we can do uh if members are uh
do vote to approve the application is
obviously consider uh what conditions
might be appropriate for the safe and
appropriate um operation of the site um
for example i know some of the debaters
talked about the height
of um of the uh
uh sorry tracy no i was just um
i was just asking you to clarify from
previous experience whether those very
special circumstances were uh applicable
but um
uh i don't think we need to go into that
i think the members have actually
confirmed what they believe is very
special circumstances so
i don't need you to clarify so yes uh a
set of conditions now please chair
thank you yeah i think i know we touched
on about the height and he touched on
about landscaping as well i think catch
the field didn't mention the height and
catch the mills sorry still the way
around catch the mills mentioned the
height and cancer phil didn't mention
the landscaping
um in particular
um i don't know what other conditions
you heard i might have missed them as
part of the debate so i apologize for
that jose if you want to it's okay
we could probably uh come up with an
appropriate list of conditions similar
to the previous committee items where
we've uh
we would draft some reasons for refusal
based on committee members views
we can do the same in relation to
planning conditions if you choose to
approve this application for example it
might be that we would want to look at
the the time frame for the operation we
would need to tie the application to the
submitted plans um landscaping
conditions i would envisage um
you know potential removal of permitted
development rights if any applied
it's a brownfield site
under 12 as12 it which refers to it's
not inappropriate in the green belt it's
a job creation site
we've also got as as10
again which is uh job creation yeah
yeah we were on about the conditions not
the uh this is what i'm aiming for these
are the conditions that i i'm arguing we
use for refusal i mean for granting
no we're on about
if
we're on about if we
agree this application the conditions
that we would need to apply for this
actual application such in terms of
height of the the bags and the
landscaping and i think the planning
managers indicated that she about to
come up taking those into account a list
of
conditions that i'm sure i can agree we
can come to some conclusion on agreement
on
um
[Music]
chair but i think we can come up with a
list of conditions yes just to clarify
that what we were suggesting there were
potential areas for conditioning on a
planning permission if that's the
decision members are imminently about to
vote on um we weren't suggesting um
reasons as to why
members wanted to uh to overturn the
recommendation because you know clearly
that's within your remit to do so if
if that's your decision today so some of
the conditions as i say
landscaping removal of permitted
development rights the height of the bag
stacking um potential dust suppression
in fairness i think the case officer and
i can look at a list of suitable
conditions um
any um
you know obviously we can devise that
and and and put that list forward
through yourself
yep
members happy with that are we
brilliant thank you
right we had a proposal and a second to
grant the application
um i think it's about zombie went to the
vote
this is banks are you able to do that
for us please
yes i am chairman can we start with you
please
for
councillor fielding councillor fielding
four
councillor fleming
angela fleming four
councillor harvey
councilman harvey four
council meals for
chairman
thank you
committee resolves to grant application
twenty slash zero zero five zero zero f
u out
i sent you a message to say we need to
take the vote on the three hours because
we are over now i just didn't want to
interrupt because you were in the debate
stage so we need to do that
uh yes i need to i'm proposing that we
carry on past the three we've gone past
the three hours to
carry on here the applications in front
of us i'm proposing that and anybody
happy to second that for me
catch the harvest second that do can we
call the votes okay mrs banks
yep
um so yourself
chairman
thank you cancer fielding for
cancer fleming
you unanimous chairman
thank you committee resolves to carry on
with the committee uh past the
three-hour
right we'll
move on um
after
we need a very short break um done
yeah well we'll need to get the um the
speakers in so if we can just we'll see
if we can get them in two minutes if
everybody can just maybe stay
yeah the recording will be cutting off
in 45 minutes so
yes
and look at that too but yes we can
come back in two minutes so it's 21 18
boliton we're back so just stretch our
legs for two seconds and get
thank you
hello
are we all back yet
right
can we carry on are we ready to start
on
yes we are chairman
right now
move on to our next item on the agenda
which is 20
000 97 slash fuel
the art school vicarage road knopton on
hill removal of two external teaching
units
provision of three new external teaching
pods
and one new
uh external cluster unit and associated
an external play area
trying to read that too quickly and our
presenting opposite is aaron please far
away when you're ready thank you
chairman please snapchat everyone can
see the presentation okay
yes i can see it just thank you great
yes
thank you the application site lies to
the east of knapton on the hill village
which is identified as a cataract ii
local service village within the
council's adopted core strategy
the site lies within the ironstone hill
special landscape area as an area of
high archaeological sensitivity
the extent of the application site is
outlined in red and has a lawful school
use with the school buildings register
school building
and external classrooms which you can
see just here
associated vehicular access from
vicarage road to the northwest of the
site
on-site parking and open areas here and
here
the site is enclosed on freeside by
neighbouring dwellings which include the
properties and collins closed to the
east of the site just here
the land across the site slopes down
towards a neighboring property from the
east
so it slopes from the road here down to
the neighboring properties to the east
planning commission is sought for the
removal of two existing teaching
buildings which are here and here
and the sighting of three external
teaching pods direction of a new
classroom with air conditioning unit and
the creation of a new wet pool play area
this slide shows a proposed site plan
for the development
the main school building is located to
the west of the plan just here
the new pods are proposed to be sited on
the area of hard standing closely
existing car park in the centre of the
plan here so three pods here
to the east of the site the new
classroom building is proposed to be
sited south of the existing in this area
just here approximately five meters from
the shared boundary to the east and 2.7
metres at the closest point from the
south
the new wet pool play area is proposed
to be located between the new classroom
building here and the existing in this
area approximately here on the plan
this slide shows the proposed floor
plans and elevations of the new pods in
classroom
proposed classroom is on the left of the
slide with a measure approximately 15.5
metres in width
6 meters in depth and 3.5 meters to the
highest point
we finished with a timber finish with
dark gray openings and roof
proposed pods would be simple in design
see just here to the right of the slide
finished with a curved roof a dark roof
and timber finish there'd be one larger
pot and two smaller pods proposed and
they all measure approximately
2.4 meters in height to the highest part
this slide shows a number of photographs
taken from vicarage road of the site and
the street scene see in this image on
the top left you've got the school just
on the left-hand side an existing
vehicular access
this image to the top right panes around
just to show the wider street scene
this photograph at the bottom left is
looking back with a school on the right
along vicarage road and again the bottom
right is looking along vicarage road you
see the existing street scene
this slide shows a number of photographs
of the western part of the application
site the top left image was taken
looking in a northern direction across
the playground
towards the existing parking area you
see this image just here the top right
was taken looking west
within the site back towards the road
you can see the
bridge road here in the background with
the existing parking
taken looking back towards the school
got the playground area just here the
new pods are proposed in this area here
and the parking you've just seen which
goes up to vicarage raid and the final
photograph is taken of the existing
units which are proposed to be removed
and the area to the rear of the school
building where the new pods are proposed
this slide shows a number of photographs
of the eastern part of the site
the top left image was taken facing in a
southern direction to show the ground
level changes you can see the existing
playground area and a land sloping down
to the east and the neighboring property
to the south in the back of the image
looking at the top right this image is
panning round you'll see a fenced area
here
and the eastern boundary of the site
just here and a land level sloping down
the bottom image shows the two classroom
units which are positioned to the
northern part of the site the eastern
boundary and the fence that encloses
that area
and the final photograph was taken from
the eastern eastern boundary of the site
looking back towards the school building
you can see here
an existing classroom unit
this slide shows a number of photographs
taken from the garden of the neighbor to
the east of the site you see taken from
the rear garden looking back towards the
application site panning to the north
you can see the buildings within the
application site looking to the south
and the bottom left image you can see
this is the approximate location of the
new classroom building and the final
photograph is looking to the north of
the application site you can see the
ridgelines of the two buildings that are
on the site from the garden of the
neighbour
there's been a number of updates for
this application which have been
circulated on the update sheet it is
recommended that planning permission be
granted subject to the conditions notes
outlined within the officer report and
on the update sheet thank you
when you need to unmute
um
oh brilliant it was stuck
honest
and what i said was brilliant it was the
best i've said all night
all right our first speaker is
councillor gordon clark from knopton
parish council may i quickly ask erin a
question no john um points of
clarification i'm afraid and we've got
to move on um sorry um
councillor clark can you come in now
please
gordon can you hear us
counselor clark
hello
counselor clark if you can hear us you
might need to press
star 6 to unmute
can you hear me now yeah we can gordon
nice to see you nice to hear you yeah
technology beats me
you've got three minutes far away when
you're ready okay good evening
councillors
as i'm sure you will have noted
there are several objections from napton
residents regarding this application
and i'm sure officers will have studied
the number of concerns put forward
especially the comprehensive assessment
made by councillor nigel rock stating
his reasons for objection
to this application and the issues and
concerns put forward
by mr mrs james whose property borders
the school grounds plus several other
affected residents
knapton parish council does share these
concerns and stands by its objection to
the application
like all parish councils one of our main
objectives is to look after the
interests of the residents
and in this application we have a case
of a commercial company although it
being one that looking after the welfare
of children
putting forward an application that will
have a negative detrimental effect on
several close by residents
especially the property that has the
boundary with the
school although we as a cancer admire
the facility the art school provides for
special needs children
we believe this site is being over
developed and this new application for a
very sizable building close to a
residential house boundary
will certainly be detrimental to those
napton residents
the plan to site this large building
alongside an existing building
plus air conditioning units so close to
the boundary of a residential property
can only be described as a bad plan
knapton parish council has in the past
supported applications made on behalf of
the art school
but in this application we believe that
development is a step too far and our
duty in this instant is to support our
residents in the belief that granting
this application would create an ongoing
harm to the immediate community without
any positive benefit to that
community therefore
we ask that the application should be
refused thank you
thank you councillor clark
uh any questions for the paris council
no
i think you must stumped everybody into
science cats look up with your concise
uh summing up
cancer mills hold on cancer car cancer
mills is just indicated
okay you can't get away uh council club
um
i usually ask everybody was there any
consultation
with the parish council on this proposed
development or alteration
uh no
no i believe not the application just
came to us
so no discussion taken place
normal channels
no we won't ask for upfront sort of
advice
advice or um discussions on it now okay
thank you thank you very much
okay thank you christopher mills
nobody else is indicated you're right
you're free to go know council clark
okay thank you very much thank you we'll
move on to our next speakers which
should be
mr ian james and mr mike cooper
hello gentlemen good evening sorry we
kept you so long um
you got three minutes between you if you
can hear me um
[Music]
we can hear you can you hear well
yes who's that can you say you are
please
let nine colin's close
boundary with the school
and uh how long of the three minutes are
you speaking for mr james
two minutes 30 seconds
and mr cooper's obviously got the other
30 seconds left and you you're going
first i see
i am yeah
right then
far away then mr james um we'll give you
uh um community services will tell you
when to stop or as close as possible um
and foreign please
we have a shallow garden and a long
boundary with a school we are not
against the school and understand the
special nature of the pupils and the
challenges this brings this is a special
educational establishment and runs as a
for-profit organization our experiences
have led us to have serious concern
one protection and security we have had
many items thrown over our fence wood
with nails sticking out manhole covers
play tunnel stones toys footballs and
even a pair of scissors that came over
our garden and landed in a neighbour's
garden i've nearly been hit on three
occasions a stone came within a foot of
my head we have three young
grandchildren that we look after
regularly we would not feel safe being
in the garden during school operating
times noise the language and noise at
times in our boundary fence has been
totally unacceptable again we would not
venture out during school times given
that we have young members of our family
that we would try and give some
protection from this environment the air
conditioning unit is currently to be
cited at a rear of a proposed building
in an acoustic corridor and will no
doubt increase the tesla level outlook
we already have two classrooms along the
boundary at four meters height the new
building is also four meters this will
have an effect on our outlook and light
in such a shallow garden and will be
overbearing we will lose light in the
late afternoon and have built a garden
and patchy area to make most of this we
were not expecting any further buildings
to be required by the school
the existing buildings house five pupils
each the new building will house a
further 10 children this means that well
over half of the maximum number of
pupils 35 will be educated along our
boundary fence my questions are one is
the purpose-built old village school not
suitable for expansion two is a no
alternative to the site in this
additional building we have no choice
the art school do
we already have had some bad experiences
and this will exacerbate them who do we
turn to if a member of our family is
injured
who do we turn to by bringing more
children near to our boundary fence it
will inevitably have consequences
request for conditions bouncing around
the new building to ensure no children
can hide and cause a nuisance close to
the boundary horizontal netting from the
building to our boundary air
conditioning to be cited at the front of
the building not the rear acoustic fence
adjacent to the boundary fence air
conditioning only to be allowed during
school operating hours and monetary
contribution to a small fence on top of
our boundary fence to allow minor
distraction planting that will not
further block light i absolutely
cannot believe that we were not
um
asked about any of this before this
application was put in given our
experiences
thank you mr james mr cooper can you
come in now please
yeah certainly so our concern is vehicle
and movements pick up and drop off
parking in vickers road
and potential increase because of the
capacity on the site even at its current
level giving residents issues in the
vicarage road the pickup and drop-off
vehicles are chewing in the in the road
causing congestion
to the area outside of school cars queue
on the zigzags outside and scoring half
on half off the curb two sometimes
blocking the pavement as waiting in
front of the gates
parking parking access has been given
outside the local church but cars
continued to park on the junction of
church staying opposite school on the
road near to the s-bend next to the
school causing cars to move into
oncoming traffic on the pavement
blocking the pavement
for safety's pedestrians mothers babies
and disabled and then furthering around
the corner from the school in the
residential section area
uh nearer to the village it's been
observed sometimes five
your times off please mr cooper
and at times cars parked at 45 degrees
on pavements that have been left there
all day causing neighbours to ask and
call the schools and have vehicles move
for inconsiderate parking issues
these will all need addressing whether
the application is granted or not
thank you thank you mr cooper
right
um right
councillors
questions to uh the neighbors of the
property please
any questions let's see what can get up
on my screen
yes i'd put one in
uh because the fielding
sorry cancel the harvest first i'm
afraid
thank you mr chairman
a question to mr james if i could
um mr james
when you moved into your house
was the school already in operation
yes it was
thank you
right uh counts the field england cancel
the cattle sorry cancer fielding
i just wanted to get clarification did
you say you wanted
to put netting above the existing fence
to stop items coming over the top of
them
no should
should the
planning application be approved we
would request some conditions that i
thought that the netting is a horizontal
netting
uh to stop
further items coming over
yeah i think the um
now
here's yep kettle
you muted chris
mr jones
um i've i've looked at the site from
google earth and i can see where your
property is
um
if the children
who have been
um throwing missiles towards your garden
which i completely understand is is
not really acceptable
if they are
en encompassed in a building on the
boundary would that offer you not offer
you some further protection on the basis
that if they're in a building it's going
to be more difficult for them to lob
anything over the fence
[Music]
sorry
i'll i'll stop i'll start that answer
again yes please
on the contrary my point is that already
there are two buildings on the boundary
center which were there they're housing
five peoples each this is another
building to house another ten so that is
20 pupils being educated along the
boundary fence
the more the children are brought down
towards our boundary center the actual
school itself is quite a long way from
our property but the more the children
are brought down to the boundary fence
the more chance whether they're moving
between the old school and the new new
buildings the more chance it is for them
to throw objects over the fence
or climb on top of the building since
we've had we've had that as well
thank you
any any further questions
um
yeah
again um whichever
you two gentlemen want to answer this
one um
i believe um
lots of pupils are coming by by the taxi
to to the site
um
and end up queuing on on the main road
uh round the bend
um
it's it's
vickery's road and butt hill but yeah i
always get mixed up so sorry my daughter
used to work at the primary school so i
do know
back um
normally but hill
and the prize martian road yeah but then
but then you have charles parking on the
zigzags in front of the school half on
half off which
is not legal i don't believe but then
as you
go around the corner past the school
you end up on a narrow
dangerous bend where it's
narrow for two cars to get five
next to a property uh just around the
corner
which then causes cars into the oncoming
traffic coming out of the village
and you've then got a service road and
properties just slightly further
teachers and helpers
yeah there was a point i was coming to
have
also i do believe that um
potentially our teachers and assistants
are parking down the road um because of
black access on site have you raised
these concerns with the school
and if so
what response have you got
uh
normally if you ask we've had instances
where people have phoned this phone
my wife has emailed the school
[Music]
generally
yeah we'll move them but the case in
question is
the allocated parking that had already
been discussed is at the parish church
and it seems to be there is a refusal to
use that in any great
numbers but the teachers would rather
dump cars to help us dump cars
in the residential area which is closer
to the school admittedly
but at the inconvenience of all the
residents
okay yep thank you for that
that's clear any further questions
no i can't do anymore thank you
gentlemen you are free to go
thank you thank you
right we'll now move on
to our award at the speaker next week is
the ward number which uh on this
occasion is councillor adam who's uh
substituting for councillor rock
councillor adam sorry for keeping you so
long you've got
five minutes so you can far away when
you're ready please
thank you very much um i'll try to keep
it concise um
i've tried to sum up the feelings of
counselor rock obviously as well as uh
coming along
the lines of his original objection
and i'll try and answer any questions as
best i can
the current pupil numbers have been
reported to be below the educational
license of 35 and 21
therefore despite the claims of this
application would not lead to an
increase in people it's not reasonable
to expect that this self-limitation of
the number of people's
from each will continue
with increased capacity being able i'll
just stop you a moment cancel adam we've
got some background noise and i'm
finding it very difficult to hear you
how fast that's much better thank you
was that your fan is it yeah it was this
thing's taking off all right
um here we go um okay sorry and um
the planning process around this
application should therefore assess the
likely reality of an increase in pupil
numbers and the impacts this will have
on the community
this therefore relates to the
consultation response provided from
county highways the site is accessible
by reasonable sustainable
modes of transport by potential users
however relevance should be given to the
nature of the business on this specific
site which attracts clients from
significant distance and overwhelming
number of whom travel by car
on the basis that this site will see an
increase in pupils the roads around the
site which are already reported to be
congested at peak times will be subject
to excess traffic
additionally given the council's
declaration of climate emergency the
increase in practical capacity sought
to be achieved by this application would
increase individual card journeys over
significant distance daily suggesting
that there are overriding
environmental impacts and the proposals
can't be seen to be promoting healthy
inclusive communities as required by
cs25
the uh in regards to residential amenity
um the levels noted in the application
of the proposal refer to the ground
level
of the building
there is however no mention of the ridge
height that i could see
um of the proposed building and this
didn't appear to be included on the
elevations i note in the officer's
report that um the height is called up
as 3.5
um however i couldn't find this in any
specific
documents although the slope across the
site is fairly uniform the gradient from
the topography increases sharply in the
neighboring property to the east
downhill of the site making the
overbearing aspects of the proposal
being building being greater than if the
slope were uniform
as per cs20 proposals must not
unacceptably detract from amenities over
any neighboring property by reason of
loss of daylight loss of privacy
overshadowing or overbearing impacts i
believe this is happening in this case
and i have witnessed myself
the aspect of the evening sunlight on
the neighbouring garden which would be
impacted by the proposed building
a section through the proposed building
including the levels of the neighboring
property showing the garden and house is
required to demonstrate this within the
application i believe this was requested
previously but has not materialized if
the assessment of the overbearing impact
has not included this then the
assessment cannot reasonably reflect the
situation as to the impact that the
proposed building will have as this is
critical aspect of the application i
believe there are grounds for refusal
in relation to noise and disturbance
similarly in relation to the impact on
the neighboring properties concerns have
been raised during the consultation
period that having a new classroom close
to the boundary may give rise to greater
noise and disturbance to neighboring
properties immediately
but the officer's report minimizes this
by considering the use of the site as a
lawful school suggesting the proposed
works not have an impact over and above
the existing relationship what this
fails to represent is that the school is
for children whose educational needs
cannot be met by mainstream setting um
specifically relating to
adhd attachment disorder autism um etc
um those are all things taken from the
school's public website
um
but did seem to be heavily redacted from
the application documents
um therefore by definition this school
is not typically uh typical to normal
school setting and so the potential for
disturbance from development close to
the boundary of this site is material in
this application
whilst respecting the need for this type
of facility in the district the
potential for disturbance is greater
than from typical schools and
introducing a new classroom directly
adjacent to the boundary can conceivably
increase this over and above the
existing relationship
this is reinforced by significant
anecdotal evidence by the neighbours of
past disturbance which obviously you've
heard tonight
if the committee is minded to grant
however i would hope that the conditions
um requested by mr james would be
considered being inclusion of a fencing
that's put around the new building to
ensure no children can get close to the
boundary and that horizontal netting
from the building to the boundary fence
be included to stop potential um for
items being thrown over
the proposed air conditioning unit will
also have a significant impact on noise
disturbance due to problems
the proposed building and the party
fence this risk has been recognized by
the environmental health response which
notes that no noise report has been
submitted if the committee is minded to
grant then i would urge a condition to
ensure that the unit is located away
from the boundary on the front of the
building the operational times for this
be restricted and that an acoustic fence
be installed along the party line as is
set out in the environmental health
consultations recommendations
right
i think i just made it
thank you thank you counselor adam any
questions for the
ward mode warden number or loco
apprentice ward member
uh
any any questions
no
he's off the hook
right um yeah thank you for that i have
noticed i've noted um
requests for conditions
um
and uh you know um again it's
disappointing as lack of luck over
reports on on the acoustics so that's
quite disappointing so
i've never did that
right thank you councillor adam you can
go back to another one of your fans
again
uh
thank you for that
we'll now move on to points of
clarification with the officer
any questions catch the mills please
then catch the flaming that building
sorry sorry
yes sir hi aaron uh erin um could you
put up on
our screen
um
uh
the the where the new rule buildings
will be
in proximity to the uh
other that's it
so
sorry councillor mills let me try
somewhere
just phrase in a second i'll just move
it up because there's a proposed site
plan
that shows the location of the new
buildings oh so here this is a classroom
unit this is a boundary approximately
five meters away
and the pods located up here
in the playground and parking out and
the you can't see me pointing and the
other side of that fence uh is a garden
is it
this fence yeah
yes that's correct so if you go this is
the site location plan this is the
extent of the garden to the east of the
site you've got part of the garden of
this property here and then the barn
which is a dwelling two bedrooms wedding
and their garden area there they've got
neighbours to the north here
right um
one of the objections is uh lots of
light i mean
you obviously looked into that area i
know you did but
it's a possibility of loss of light with
the new buildings there
so we would assess um any impact on
neighbouring properties in line with our
fsbd um we're looking at habitable
windows but we also look at garden areas
as well so if i just bring up the
photographs of the neighboring property
this is the neighboring property to the
east of the site nine collins clothes so
they have got a patio area here we would
give more weight to private amenity
areas so normally that's private patio
areas which are close to the dwelling
house you can see the property just here
but we have to consider as well the size
of the garden and the relationship so it
will be visible the new building will be
visible approximately here and offices
of recommended conditions in terms of
sections and levels to make sure that
the levels are in accordance with the
details that have been provided um and
the height of the building is 3.5 meters
and they'll be setting it five meters
from the boundary of crosstalk
thanks so sorry
oh we
one question so that's it thank you
all right uh who's next uh catch the
fielding please
cancer ferdinand cancer cattle can we
keep these questions succinctly can i
ask two short quick questions yes please
one is in this picture that you've got
up here on the right hand side that
ridge height is that another property
or is that part and parcel of the school
so you can see just here in the top
right and this one here in the bottom
right as well these are the two
buildings that have been approved within
the application site and they're
permanently sighted on the land
and just to give you an idea we've got
3.6 meters to the ridge of this building
and the floor level is 30 centimeters
higher than what we're looking at for
the finished floor level of the new
classroom building so just to give you
an idea of context of height these
heights obviously these are pitch roof
buildings so it's slightly different in
terms of the relationship to the
boundary
okay and the other question is what are
the pods for
so the pods are to provide extra
learning spaces for one-to-one
because of the i understand based on the
planning statement submitted
because of the needs of the students of
the schools they have more one-to-one
sessions so the pods would be for those
sessions and what are the ages of the
pupils one more
i think we can move on i think we've
answered the question on that one um
cancer cattle please
all right thank you mr
um
are you there
right is it possible to condition that a
fence is put to prevent access to the
space between the boundary fence
and the new
building that is proposed to be built on
the boundary to prevent children
accessing that gap
in terms of the conditions that have
been put forward we have
proposed a fence in line with
environmental health recommendations and
but that would be just to the rear of
the building um along the boundary we
need to make sure any conditions would
be reasonable
and meet the test set out in the mppf
and so that's just something in terms of
how the site is going to be used and
whether or not
it would be something we wouldn't
normally look to put those sort of
conditions in um
but you know it's remember to consider
whether or not they feel they meet the
tests and would be necessary in this
case
but if it's to protect the immunity of
the immediate neighbor
uh given the um and i use the word
guardedly but the alleged history of of
um items being thrown over the fence
would that be something which would be
could be reasonable under the mppf
i mean to my mind we need to consider
the lawful use of the site as a school
um and
that's that's a lawful use at the moment
we've got a specialist school that's
occupying the site but it could be any
school that looks to occupy the site in
the future um we could always if you
thought it might be helpful it might be
something that could be added as a note
to consider extra treatment along the
boundary because i understand that the
concerns are arising at the moment
already
linked to the existing lawful school use
rather than as a result of the
development that's proposed
okay
right any further
points where are running rapidly at the
time um
so
uh two things one uh mr nash um i think
we're gonna have to definitely defer
the last item
um
that when definitely not gonna be glad
to get through in the four hours
uh yeah that is true chair and if we
don't complete in five minutes then
we'll lose this application as well so
that will be deferred till next time as
well
okay
right so uh do i just need to vote on on
the last one first the um the last
application to defer
yeah uh
because you're running out of time chair
it stands like it'll be deferred anyway
so okay okay so the cut off time is four
hours so 10 o'clock yeah off it goes
that's it okay
um we need to go to the debate
who wants to come in on this one catch
the males
thank you
yeah yeah um uh
some sympathy i have to say sorry oh in
some sympathy or a lot of sympathy with
the with the neighbors
on the last application we took a lot of
notice of the ward member and the parish
council
i'm not happy about this one mr chairman
i have to say i'll be very brief thank
you
right
uh
i'd like to propose as i set out
before mills
uh
proposed rock has the building i would
go along with the planning officer um
providing that we provide a
suitable vertical net to prevent
items being thrown over the top because
i think that basically it's already a
school all they're doing is putting some
new buildings in and so i
agree to go along with the officer
okay thank you council folding
catch the kettle
thank you mr
i think
um erin has laid out the case for this
very clearly
um
clearly
the nature of the school
does put significant pressures on the
immediate neighbors
um
but we have heard that the school has
been in existence for some time before
the immediate neighbor has acquired
their own house
um
therefore
i'm very sympathetic to their view but i
think in planning grounds it's very
difficult to look for
obvious reasons for refusal on this
particularly if we can condition
uh an accounts of fielding's recommended
netting
um and i wonder whether
um separation distance could be built
into those conditions as i suggested
earlier on um and on that
so that the neighbors are protected
but school is allowed to continue what
is clearly a service to those
who are challenged by the um
[Music]
conditions they have
um so i'm i'm inclined to support the
application i'll listen to what i just
have to say
uh anybody
we've had a proposal we've um catch the
kettle sort of indicated support
anybody else would like to come and
speak on this one
potentially
consultation i know the area well um and
also the potential
um taxis etc but yeah i've got concerns
about this one so um but um we've had a
proposal uh is anybody
going to second that proposal or
are we carrying on with the debate for a
minute or so i'll second
so that's councillor harvey
um
so we've had a proposal from cats the
fielding to
accept with the conditions
and seconded by cancer harvey i think we
need to go to the vote on this one
mrs banks can you do this please
determine yourself
against
the fielding
agree
four
four i'm four sorry
upstone
onto the kettle
uh paul
councillor mills
against
chairman two three four four two against
one upstairs
committee resolved to grant application
oh conditions and before do that um
will the conditions be agreed with the
with the chairman
yes
yeah
mr chairman but i would very much like
that separation distance if that can be
enforceably put in place along with the
netting that council fieldings
recommended no chair we've already gone
through this um that should have been
done beforehand
i didn't suggest it beforehand
we both did yeah but it wasn't voted on
it wasn't actually part of the actual
proposal
the two councillors who put it forward
did not actually confirm that that was
part of the actual conditions
can we confirm now
we've just voted
mr chairman that slightly concerns me
because it's quite clear
um from
council fieldings
earlier proposal that there would be
those the netting would put in place
when he put the proposal forward and it
was that was never challenged by anybody
else or by officers
yeah i sort of don't tend to agree on
tend to agree with that as well um
so
um
[Music]
i think we need to come up with some
conditions that um
that are lawful and measurable and
appropriate
um
and
if committee is happy to delegate those
two
discussions with myself and the officer
yes
agreed
sure i just need a bit of clarification
on this i'm afraid um can i ask um
whether and actually
heard a recording of that i'm fine if it
was mentioned as part of the proposal
then that's fine by me but it is not
mentioned
then basically you took the vote on the
conditions that set out in the report
so can and confirm that council fully
actually said something about the
the fencing or the netting
uh i i did hear something about the
netting but i couldn't be
100 certain that it was a condition to
be included in the force
that's the problem that i have
right
i i'm certain that i did mention
that
um the proposal including the fencing
because it is important
okay did council harvey also know that
and did he pick that up when he was
actually
uh seconding that uh proposal yes that
was my understanding and interpretation
okay that's that's fine then chair yeah
but i i think it needs to be um
the actual condition needs to be
clarified uh with yourself
um
once um
once the details are to be confirmed
i'm happy to agree that
okay
so just uh put that at the end of the
resolution uh subject to yourself
confirming uh matters with regard to the
netting fencing etcetera yeah so
committee resolves to grant application
009 to 7 ful
with conditions to be agreed with the
officer and the chairman
after
um
this will cut out at any minute we may
not still be recording it seems to be
still live but we must have seconds left
so we need to take a vote to defer
the final item if that's the way the
committee
i thought caroline said it automatically
goes to deferral because the times cut
off anyway so we didn't have to vote
yeah okay it's only a reason if it was
cut off automatically but as we're not
cut off at the moment and lycan said we
should vote on it yeah i agree yeah
i thought it was amazing
sorry sorry counselor building can we
just go through a counsellor call
four
councillor fielding for
chancellor
mails
okay that's unanimous chairman so the
final item will be deferred to the next
available meeting
thank you
and i there's no urgent business because
we haven't got time for it if there was
anyway
and i did declare the meeting closed and
thank you everybody for that help and
cooperation
sorry it's taking a
lot longer and well done everybody
that was
you